ON THEIR WAY HERE BUT NOW AND
WE GOT MILITARY FOLKS HERE SO
WE GOT TO BE ON TIME RIGHT. FOR
IT FOURTEEN HUNDRED HOURS I
GUESS FORTINO SIX NOW BUT WE
WANT TO OBVIOUSLY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND WELCOME
THE VERY FIRST HEARING OF THIS
SESSION OF THE ARE SELECT.
SELECT COMMITTEE ON DEFENSE AND
AEROSPACE AND OBVIOUSLY WELL
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE SO PLEASED TO
BE HAVING THIS HEARING TOGETHER
WITH OUR FRIENDS FROM THAT
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WHO OF COURSE
OVERSEE THE DIFFICULT AND
IMPORTANT ISSUES RELATING TO
LICENSURE. I HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR PROFESSIONS I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ENGAGING IN THIS DYNAMIC TOP BY
TOPIC I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT CAREER PORTABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS AND
MILITARY SPOUSES HAS AS BECOME
A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE IT'S
BEEN ONE THAT'S BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT FOR A LONG TIME.
COUNTY STATE GOVERNMENT'S WEST
JUST ACTUALLY HAD A WHOLE
SESSION ON THIS AT THEIR ANNUAL
CONFERENCE IN MONTANA MY WIFE
IS ACTUALLY READING BECOMING
RIGHT NOW THOUGH MICHELLE OBAMA
BOOKING APPARENTLY IS A WHOLE
SECTION THERE ABOUT HOW SHE
WANTED TO TAKE ON HI THIS ISSUE
AND OBVIOUSLY WAS ABLE TO MAKE
SOME PROGRESS BUT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE ALL STILL. I
STRUGGLING HERE BECAUSE OF THIS.
FASCINATING DYNAMIC BETWEEN THE
STATE'S RIGHTS TO. MANAGE ITS
OWN LICENSOR ROLES BUT ALSO OUR
NATIONAL NEED. TOWARD A HAVING
A MILITARY THAT REALLY WORKS
FOR FAMILIES. SO THIS IS THIS
IS CERTAINLY A PART OF THE
CHALLENGE I DO WANT TO. SPEND A
MOMENT ALSO TO THINK I WAS HERE
MASON FROM BEING P. AND- AND
OUR OUR FANTASTIC STAFFER WITH
WITH WITH THE DEFENSE AND
AEROSPACE LENA. WHOSE I THINK
TO THEM OF JUST PULL TOGETHER
REALLY FANTASTIC HEARING I'M
AND I'M I REALLY YOU KNOW.
THERE'S A LOT OF STAFF WORK
THAT GOES. INTO MAKING THESE
HEARINGS WORKING PLAN TOGETHER
THESE REALLY GUY INFORMATIVE
PACKETS AND- WHICH HAVE SO MUCH
GOOD INFORMATION AND THEN I
JUST WANT TO. TAKE. A MOMENT TO
THANK. THE TWO OF YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS. SO LET'S
JUST CHAT CHAT REALLY BRIEFLY
ABOUT ABOUT WHY WE'RE HERE. YOU
KNOW COMPARED TO THE- CIVILIAN
POPULATION. U. S. MILITARY
SPOUSES AND VETERANS FACE.
SPECIAL CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH. THEIR EMPLOYMENT MILITARY
SPOUSES MOVE ACROSS STATE
LINES. SEVEN TO TEN TIMES MORE
OFTEN. THAN THEIR CIVILIAN
COUNTERPARTS I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY. SURPRISE THERE.
THROUGHOUT THEIR CAREERS
BECAUSE OF THE WAY OUR MILITARY
WORKS IN THE BECAUSE THE WAY
THAT WE- WE DO STAFFING THERE
AND I THINK AS A RESULT IT'S
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATIONS. REFLECTS A NEED
FOR SPOUSAL CAREER PORTABILITY
TO EASE. NEW RESIDENT.
TRANSITIONS AT THE TIME IT
TAKES TO ACQUIRE LICENSE.
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE LICENSES
PORTABILITY. IN A LACK OF
TEMPORARY OR PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE OPPORTUNITIES ALL CAN
NEGATIVELY IMPACT EMPLOYMENT
OPTIONS AND REALLY. IMPACT.
FAMILIES PORTABILITY AND
WELFARE. AND HERE'S INTERESTING
THING THAT THE WE KNOW FOR THAT
70% OF ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY YOU
FIND THEMSELVES TRANSITIONING%
INTO CIVILIAN LIFE. TELL US THE
DIFFICULTY IN FINDING A JOB
WHICH MAY BE EXACERBATED BY
LICENSING REGULATIONS IS A TOP
CHALLENGE. SO CALIFORNIA HAS
COMMITTED IT'S HAS DEMONSTRATES
COMMITMENT TO USING MANY OF THE
BEARS FOR MILITARY SPOUSES AND
VETERANS WE HAVE PASSED A
COUPLE BILLS IN THE PAST THAT.
THAT ARE IN THIS ARE IN THIS
AREA YOU KNOW SILLY BILL
NINETEEN OH FOUR AND A. B. ONE
EIGHTY SIX. THEY WERE PASSED
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN RESPECT
WITH THIS. I HAVE. IMPORTANT I
CAN GROUNDWORK IN THIS AREA BUT
WE STILL AYE AYES WILL LEARN
TODAY WE HAVE A LITTLE WAYS TO
GO ON IMPROVING AND BUILDING
UPON THOSE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION. HI YOU KNOW. SO
LET'S HEAR DURING TALK ABOUT
POLICIES CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT REALLY TO
VARIOUS LICENSING BOARDS. WE'RE
GONNA TALK BUT AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT FOR CURRENT
LICENSING REGULATIONS WERE TALK
ABOUT PORTABILITY MODELS FROM
OTHER STATES WE'RE GONNA HEAR
ACCOUNTS FROM OUR MILITARY
REGARDING CHALLENGES THEY FACE
REGARDING. CAREER PORTABILITY I
LEARN ABOUT CAL THAT'S
PROGRAMMING FOR VETERAN
TRANSITION ASSISTANCE TAKE
TESTIMONY FOR MILITARY SPOUSE.
CAREER PORTABILITY SPECIALIST
AND MILITARY SPOUSES
THEMSELVES. ARE SO THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD STUFF THAT WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT HERE I'M
REALLY HOPING THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO HELP ADDRESS. SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THROUGH
LEGISLATION REGULATION THAT
COULD GET HELP TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE RAISING TODAY. AT THE
HEARING SO WITHOUT ALL OF TO
OPEN. THE FLOOR TO REMARKS FROM
OUR OUR CHAIR OF BEING P. AND
THEN ALSO. OTHER MEMBERS BEFORE
WE GET STARTED. WITH THAT AS
THE HEARING. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALLEN I THINK IS THE STATE
IN A. ARE VERY ARTICULATE WAY
WE DO KNOW THAT LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS CAN CREATES A
BURDENS ON FAMILIES I IN THE
MILITARY AND WE KNOW THAT. THAT
THE MILITARY LIFE IS ONE THAT
DOES REQUIRE RELOCATION. THE
CENTRAL QUESTION THAT I THINK
WE ALL WANNA WE HOPE THIS
HEARING WILL REALLY ILLUMINATE.
IS WHAT STEPS CAN WE TAKE TO
EASE THE POTENTIAL BURDEN FOR
LICENSURE AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS WHEN THAT'S THE
CENTRAL QUESTION WHICH I HOPE
WILL GET OUT OF THAT WONDERFUL
TESTIMONY THAT WE'RE GONNA HEAR
TODAY. UP WHILE OUR DISCUSSIONS
NARROWLY FOCUSED ON THAT THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE I HOPE IN THE COMING
YEAR AND IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS
IS IT. WILL LOOK AT THE BROADER
ISSUE OF LICENSURE. LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS IN A WHOLE RANGE
OF OTHER AREAS I KNOW WE TALKED
A LITTLE BIT. OVER THE SUMMER
AT SHARE ALLEN ABOUT THAT. AND
SO FOR ME IT'S THE JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THIS TYPE OF
IMPORTANT EXAMINATION THAT WILL
START TODAY. THAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT CAN MEET IN THIS HEARING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. THAT
I ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM OTHER
MEMBERS OF OKAY LET'S GO LET'S
GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED AND
MOM HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A
GOOD. DISCUSSION WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THE HEAT WITH THE
PANEL ON MILITARY SPOUSE
VETERAN LICENSE OR STATUS AND
NEEDS. WE'VE GOT A KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS IS HERE FROM DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE. SHE ACTS AS ONE OF
SEVERAL. DEFENSE STATE LIAISONS
THAT THAT COVER DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE OF THE COUNTRY I THINK
YOU'VE GOT THE SOUTHWEST. AS
PART OF YOUR- YOUR YOUR YOUR
AREA WITH ANY PRO OAKLEY USE
MANAGER OF THE OFFICE OF
STUDENTS IS IT'S A REALLY FOR
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS. I
APRIL OAKLEY. OUR GUIDE AARON
SCREWBALL WHOSE INTERIM
DIRECTOR OF CERTIFICATION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING WHICH OF
COURSE IS. ONE AREA OF REAL
NEED IN THIS AREA AND FINALLY
AB UNIONS WHO'S THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BARS OFFICE OF ADMISSIONS
OPEN TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH LAWYERS AND
LICENSOR THERE SO WHAT WE GET
START WITH YOU. I MISSED A
LISTEN REALLY APPRECIATE. YOU
BEING HERE. THANK YOU CHAIR
ALLEN CHERRY GLAZER. AND IS THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES. MY
NAME IS KELLY MAY DOUGLAS'S
CENTER ALLEN MENTIONED ON
BEHALF OF DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
AND MILITARY FAMILIES. I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE FOR OPENING UP THIS
VENUE FOR TALKING ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I'M- IN IN
HELPING US TO ENGAGE IN A
MEANINGFUL AN OUTCOME. ORIENTED
CONVERSATION ON THE ISSUE OF
LICENSURE AND THE LARGER ISSUE
OF CAREER PORTABILITY. FOR THE
MILITARY COMMUNITY AND I'M
PARTICULARLY FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES. WITH THAT SAID I'LL GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED AND WE
HAVE A- TAPE. SCHEDULE HERE SO
MY OFFICE IS THAT THE DEFENSE
STATE LIAISON OFFICE I IT WE
WORK UNDER THE MILITARY
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY POLICY
DEPARTMENT UNDER. THE ASSISTANT
DEPUTY A DETECTIVE MEDIA
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
FOR. FOR PERSONAL READINESS. SO
OUR OFFICE WORKS ON
SPECIFICALLY ON AND STATE
POLICY BASICALLY WELL WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS TRYING TO
HARMONIZE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
FEDERAL AND STATE POLICY. ON
BEHALF OF SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND WE DEAL
MOSTLY WITH QUALITY OF LIFE
TYPE TYPE ISSUES. IN THE PAST
WE WORKED ON FAMILY LAW
EDUCATION OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSURE EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT
CONSUMER VOTING I PROTECTION
VOTING PROTECTIONS FOR NATIONAL
GUARD AND THE STATE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM. WE'VE ALSO WORKED AND
IN PARTICULAR OUR FOCUS RIGHT
NOW IS ON AND STUFF LIKE CENTER
IN ON K. TWELVE EDUCATION I'LL
TALK MORE ABOUT THAT AND LITTLE
BIT. UNDERWEAR ISSUES COME UP
AND YOU BECOME UP AT THEIR
BROUGHT TO US ANNUALLY
SUBMITTED BY THE SERVICE
BRANCHES AND OTHERS KEY
STAKEHOLDERS WE REVIEW THEM
RESEARCH THEM. ASCERTAIN THE
APPLICABILITY ACROSS THE STATE
IT'S FOR THESE POLICY ISSUES
AND WE HIGHLIGHT AND FOCUS ON
THOSE THAT ARE MOST HABITABLE
ACROSS ALL. ALL OF THE STATE.
TWO I WOULD LIKE TO USE THIS
TERM IN THE MILITARY BOTTOM
LINE UP FRONT SO NOW YOU KNOW
WHEN EXTRA MILITARY TERM BLUFF
SO. THE MILITARY SPOUSE TODAY
IS OUR FOCUS IS MY FOCUS AND I
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT. CONDITIONING SERVICE
MEMBERS AS WELL AS VETERANS AS
WELL AND ANY TO ANY POLICY THAT
BENEFITS MILITARY SPOUSES IS
GOING TO BENEFIT THOSE THOSE
POPULATIONS AS WELL. MY
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON MILITARY
SPOUSES IS JUST ACKNOWLEDGING
THE- FREQUENT TRANSITION THAT
THEY AN INDOOR AND THAT IT IS
THIS REPETITIVE DESTRUCTION OF
THEIR CAREER THAT HAS THE
IMPACT ON. THEIR CAR CAREER
SISTINE ABILITY ATTAINMENT AND
ALSO THEIR FAMILY'S FINANCIAL
STABILITY SO IT BECAUSE OF
THOSE REASONS THAT'S JUST OUR
FOCUS RIGHT NOW BUT AGAIN
ANYTHING WE DO CAN BE APPLIED
ACROSS THE BOARD. AND WE
DEFINITELY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HIGHLIGHT AND ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF VETERANS AND
TRANSITIONING SERVICE MEMBERS
AS WELL. SO MILITARY SPELLS
MOBILITY IS NOT A CHOICE HAVING
PUTTING THAT UP FRONT IT YOU
SOME MIGHT THINK THAT IT'S A
CHOICE BUT IT'S NOT A VIABLE
CHOICE FOR FAMILIES SO WE KNOW
THAT WHEN I'M- CIVILIAN
COUNTERPARTS IN SIMILAR
SITUATION AS MILITARY SPOUSES.
REALIZE THE DIFFICULTY THAT
MIGHT INCUR FROM THE MOVE THEY
MIGHT HAVE THE OPTION TO CHOOSE
NOT TO MOVE WHERE MILITARY
SPOUSE THERE'S TWO OPTIONS THEY
CAN CHOOSE NOT TO MOVE AND
DISRUPT THEIR ENTIRE FAMILY OR
THEY CAN NOT THEY CAN CHOOSE
NOT TO PURSUE THEIR LICENSE IN
THAT STATE. IS OBVIOUSLY STILL
CREATING A DISTRACTION FOR THE
FAMILY AS FAR AS ECONOMICS. SO
IT'S NOT A CHOICE IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S A LOSING PROPOSITION FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES IN TERMS OF
MOBILITY AND MOBILITY IS GOT IS
DIRECTED BY THEIR SPOUSE THEIR
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBER OR
RESERVE AND THEY'RE ACTING
THERE'D SERVICE MEMBERS COMMAND
AND MISSION REQUIREMENTS.
MILITARY SPOUSES ARE HIGHLY
SKILLED AND HIGHLY EDUCATED I
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT. BUT
SEE. 32% AND THEY'RE ALL OF THE
NUMBERS ACROSS THE BORDER
HIGHER THAN THEIR AVERAGE BUT
32% OF MILITARY SPOUSES HAVE A
GRADUATE OR PROFESSIONAL DEGREE
VERSES 12% FOR THE CAT
COUNTERPARTS IN CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THESE THESE ARE HIGH I
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT YOU
KNOW AND YOU THERE ACROSS THE
BOARD YOU HAVE YOUR SPOUSE'S IN
EVERY INDUSTRY BUT BUT AS FAR
AS I'M KIND OF BREAKING SOME
STEREO TYPES ABOUT MILITARY
SPOUSES BEING YOUNG AROUND
EDUCATED THEY'RE- THEY'RE
HIGHLY EDUCATED. AND THERE IS A
HUGE ASSET TO THE STATE. I
THEY'RE ALSO SO SPELL SO CAREER
SATISFACTION AND FAMILY
ECONOMIC SECURITY AFFECTS
MILITARY RETENTION THAT SAID
IT'S A KEY THEME THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT A LOT AND
YOU'LL HEAR IT FROM OTHERS BUT
60% OF MARRIED SERVICE MEMBERS
HAVE REPORTED THAT THEIR
SPOUSES ABILITY TO MAINTAIN A
CAREER IMPACTS THEIR DOES
DECISION TO STAY IN THE
MILITARY BY A LARGE OR MODERATE
EXTENT IN ADDITION 77% OF
MILITARY SPOUSES HAVE INDICATED
THAT THE ON IN A SURVEY THAT
THEY EITHER WANTED OR NEEDED TO
WORKS OF SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT.
AND WHEN WE GO INTO THE
DEMOGRAPHICS YOU'LL SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT THAT
THAT THAT WANTING OR NEEDING TO
WORK IN IN THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
THOSE WORKING AND WE THINK THAT
LICENSURE BARRIERS ARE PART OF
THAT PART OF THAT KIND OF
EQUATION. FINALLY MILITARY
SPOUSE LICENSING IN EMPLOYMENT
IS OF ECONOMICS ITS IMPORTANCE
TO STATES PRIMARILY FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF SUSTAINING
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS AND THE
THREE SERVICE SECRETARIAT.
RECENTLY LAST YEAR PUT OUT A
LETTER SENT A LETTER TO THE
NATIONAL GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION
IS STATING THAT K. TWELVE
EDUCATION AND MILITARY SPOUSE
EMPLOYMENT. AND LICENSURE WOULD
BE ONE OF THE CONSIDERATIONS
WHEN LOOKING AT BASING
DECISIONS THAT LETTER IT SHOULD
BE AND YOUR PACKETS AND IT'S IN
THE IT'S ALSO AND CONTAINED IN
THE- SENATE ARMS SERVICES
COMMITTEE REPORT FROM MARCH OF
THIS YEAR. ALRIGHT SO IS FAR AS
DEMOGRAPHICS I'M NOT GOING TO
GO THROUGH ALL THIS I DID WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF KEY
POINTS THE NUMBER ONE KEY POINT
IS THAT. MILITARY SPOUSES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
LICENSE LICENSING BARRIERS. SO
YOU CAN SEE I DON'T BECAUSE HAS
A POINT OR DOES IT. OKAY I'M
I'M I'M NOT GONNA CHECK. OKAY
SO IF YOU LOOK DOWN BUT SEE THE
PART I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT WAS
SO CALIFORNIA ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY SPOUSES SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. THAT NUMBER IS
IMPORTANT IT'S TWENTY IT'S 12%
OF THE TOTAL US MILITARY SPOUSE
POPULATION IS JUST JUST IN
CALIFORNIA OF THAT NUMBER FORTY
SIX OVER FORTY SIX THOUSAND OR
IN THE WORK FORCE. SO IT'S 61%
OF THE MILITARY SPOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN THE WORK
FORCE. AND THEN THE POINT I
REALLY WANTED TO DRIVE DOWN WAS
THE NEXT ONE SO THOSE MILITARY
SPOUSES THAT ARE IN THE WORK
FORCE THAT REQUIRE LICENSURE OR
CERTIFICATION IS FIFTH AVE
ALMOST SIXTEEN THOUSAND WHICH
IS 34% OF THE WORKING FORCE. OF
CALIFORNIA MILITARY SPOUSES. SO
34% OF MILITARY SPOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THAT NUMBER
IS THE SAME NATIONWIDE REQUIRE
A LICENSED PROFESSION. COMPARED
221% OF CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
POPULATION SO 21% OF CALIFORNIA.
WORKING POPULATION REQUIRES A
LICENSE 34% COMPARED 234% A
MILITARY SPOUSE COMMUNITY. 22%
NATIONWIDE SO IT'S SIMILAR TO
CALIFORNIA SO NATION WIDE
TWENTY TWO CALIFORNIA TWENTY
ONE MILITARY SPOUSE THIRTY FOUR.
IN ADDITION THEIR MILITARY
SPOUSES MOVE BETWEEN. ANYWHERE
BETWEEN TWO AND FOUR YEAR EVERY
TWO IN FOUR YEARS THEY'RE
MOVING A LOT SO ON TOP OF
HAVING A HIGHER NUMBER OF THAT
THE WORKING SPOUSES THAT NEED A
LICENSE ON TOP OF THAT THEY'RE
MOVING. AS CENTER ALLEN SAID
SEVEN TO TEN TIMES MORE THAN
THEIR COUNTERPARTS. AND EACH SO
FOR EACH MOVE 73% OF A MILITARY
SPOUSE PROFESSIONALS ARE HAVING
TO APPLY FOR REAL WE LICENSURE.
BEFORE THEY CAN MARK SO IT'S A
BIG IT'S A BIG DEAL IT REALLY
DOES IT'S A DISPROPORTIONATE.
IMPACT ON MILITARY SPOUSES
VERSES THE GENERAL POPULATION
OF THOSE WHO MIGHT BE MOVING AS
WELL. SO I'M NOT GOING TO GO
INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL HERE I CAN
SHARE INFORMATION OFFLINE LATER
BUT WE DO GET ASKED A LOT YOU
KNOW HOW IT HOW DOES DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE CONTRIBUTE TO THIS EVER
OF HELPING SPOUSES. WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROGRAMS IN PLACE THE
SPOUSE EDUCATION CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM MY CA AND
AS C. P. AND THEN INSTALLATION
EACH INSTALLATION HAS FAMILY
MEMBER EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT
PROGRAMS. ON TOP OF THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS SINCE SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS. LAST YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NDA
AUTHORIZED EACH OF THE SERVICE
BRANCHES TO REIMBURSE SPOUSES
FOR AT FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
LICENSURE RELATED FEES. OF A
TOOK THE SERVICE BRANCHES
AWHILE TO IMPLEMENT THAT BUT
IT'S FINALLY AND IMPLEMENTATION.
YES SIR FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
EACH MILITARY SPOUSE AS A
REIMBURSEMENT. IN EACH BRAND
YOU CAN GO ONLINE IT'S ONLINE
AS FAR AS HOW THOSE PROGRAMS
WORK AND THEN AND THEN FINALLY
MY DEPARTMENT IS PART
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE AND WE ARE
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STATE GOVERNMENTS IMPROVE
LICENSURE PORTABILITY THROUGH
POLICY CHANGE. A SO IS FAR AS
THE KIND OF LOOKING AT THE
LOOKING AT THE ISSUE AND
LOOKING AT IT HISTORICALLY. ART
MY OFFICE IS BEEN WORKING ON
LICENSURE SERVICE MEMBER
VETERAN AND SPOUSE LICENSURE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IT
SINCE THAT TIME WE IN A ACT WE
HELPED ENACT SIXTY NINE BILLS
IN FORTY SEVEN STATES MOST OF
THEM FOCUS ON LICENSURE BY
ENDORSEMENT. TEMPORARY
LICENSURE AN EXPEDITED
APPLICATION PROCESSING THEY
MOSTLY COVERED HEALTHCARE AND
COMMERCIAL OCCUPATIONS AND THEY
DID NOT INCLUDE MODE BY AND
LARGE DID NOT INCLUDE TEACHERS
AND ATTORNEYS BECAUSE THERE.
THEY WERE LICENSE THROUGH.
OUTSIDE ENTITIES FROM THE MAIN
KIND OF FOCUS THAT WE HAD WITH
A CONSUMER AFFAIRS. SO.
CALIFORNIA TIME AS FAR AS
CALIFORNIA'S PLACE A NIGHT IN
THAT TIME FRAME WE'VE THESE ARE
I'M SPECIFIC TO ENACTED
LEGISLATION ON A LICENSURE AND
NOT JUST FOR SPOUSES BUT FOR
MILITARY AND VETERANS. SO THERE
YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT
DONE IN DOD WANTS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
WORKED HARD THESE LAST FEW
YEARS OUR LAST DECADE I GUESS.
YOU KNOW TRYING TO MAKE ENTRY
INCREMENTAL CHANGE AND TO
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
THE ONLY I'M KIND OF TAKE AWAY
I HAVE IS KIND OF TWO POINTS
ONE IS YOU KNOW WE DEFINITELY
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS. TO IS IN
SPITE OF ALL OF THIS JUST AS IN
THE PREVIOUS SLIDE WHERE WE DID
PASS ALL THOSE BILLS ACROSS
THEY GET. OR CONTRIBUTE TO
THOSE BILLS BEING PASSED ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES. WE STILL
HAVE. AN ISSUE SO IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE WERE
STILL HEARING. EVEN AFTER ALL
THESE BILLS IN ALL THE STATES
WE ARE STILL HEARING FEEDBACK
FROM SPOUSES THAT THEY WERE
STILL EXPERIENCING MAJOR
CHALLENGES AND LICENSING AND SO
WE WONDERED YOU KNOW WE DID ALL
THIS WORK THE STATE'S DID ALL
THIS WORK WHAT WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM. AND SO WE DID IT WE
CHARTERED AS A STUDY WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA. IN ALL
FIFTY STATES AND SIX WE
SELECTED SIX AREAS AS A
SNAPSHOT IN THOSE AREAS ARE
COMMONLY THEY'RE NOT NOT ALL OF
THEM ARE THE TOP OCCUPATIONS.
BUT A LOT OF THESE OCCUPATIONS
ARE COMMONLY. I GUESS IT YET
UTILIZED BY MILITARY SPOUSES.
SO I WE FOUND THAT FORTY TWO
STATES WERE PROVIDING TEMPORARY
LICENSING THIRTY NINE WERE
MAKING ENDORSEMENT OF EXISTING
LIGHT LE LICENSES AVAILABLE AND
THIRTY ONE WERE X. EXPEDITING
THE PROCESS AND I THAT'S A
MISTAKE THERE'S ACTUALLY THEY
WERE NOT EXPEDITING THE PROCESS
OF GETTING A LICENSE EXPEDITING
THE PROCESS OF APPLYING FOR A
LICENSE IS WHAT THAT FOUND. AND
WHAT WE FOUND WAS THE NEWS
THREE THOSE THREE APPROACHES
ENDORSEMENT TEMPORARY AND AN
EXPEDITED DID NOT RELIEVE THE
UNDERLYING BURDEN OF LICENSING
IT ONLY MADE THE PROCESS OF
APPLYING FASTER AND WE ALSO
FOUND THE BOARDS WERE NOT
UNIFORMLY IMPLEMENTING STATE
LAWS. I WERE CALIFORNIA STOOD
WITH THAT WAS THAT CALIFORNIA
HAD TEMPORARY LICENSING FOR
NINE PROGRAMS AND- EXPEDITED
LICENSING FOR MILITARY SPOUSES
BUT DID NOT HAVE REAL A REAL
AND STILL DOES NOT HAVE A REAL
EASY ENDORSEMENT PROCESS. AND I
JUST WANNA LEAVE THIS HERE I'M
NOT GOING TO READ THIS BUT I.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SPOUSES ARE
GOING TO BE PROVIDING THE SAME
KIND OF TESTIMONY BUT THE FIRST
EXAMPLE DOES SHOW THIS IS I'M A
MILITARY SPOUSE TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA I THINK
AND THE TEACHER THAT CALIFORNIA
AND- COMMISSION TEACHER A CUT A
CREDENTIALING IS PROBABLY AN
EXAMPLE OF A LIKE A MODEL
EXAMPLE OF A OF A BOARD THAT.
THAT YOU KNOW KIND OF HAD THE
POLICIES ARE THAT ARE IN PLACE
FOR TEACHERS IS PROBABLY MORE
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR OTHER BOARDS. BUT
IT WITH THAT THERE'S STILL A
HUGE YOU KNOW KIND OF BURDEN
FOR MILITARY SPOUSES IN TERMS
OF THE PROCESS OF GETTING
VALIDATING. THEIR PREVIOUS
LICENSE AND THE EXPIRY AYE
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY I HAVEN'T
CONTACT OLD EMPLOYERS TO GET
THEM TO CONTACT THE STATE TO
GIVE THEIR EVALUATIONS AND SUCH
SO. EVEN IN A GOOD CASE
SCENARIO OUR SPOUSES ARE STILL
EXPERIENCING ISSUES AND THEN
THE SECOND ONE WAS REGARDING A
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST AND-
I AND NOW I'M IN A PIGGY BACK
ON. UP FROM THAT EXAMPLE IT
AFTER AT THE END OF THIS SO I
JUST. WANTED TO KIND OF POINT
OUT THAT YOU KNOW. THE STORY
LINE IS THIS WE'VE DONE A LOT.
AND WE'VE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND WE DEFINITELY
APPLY CALIFORNIA FOR IT FOR
WHAT IT'S DONE BY EVEN DESPITE
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE WE'RE STILL EXPERIENCING
ISSUES AND THAT. LEADS ME TO
WHAT WHEN I CLOSE KIND OF SOME
OF. OUR IDEAS FOR IMPROVEMENT.
THANK YOU. THE CARD RECEDED I
WILL NEXT YEAR FROM APRIL
OAKLEY FROM DCA. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRS ALLEN GLAZER IN MEMBERS.
OAKLEY MANAGER OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
OFFICE OF STUDENT ASSISTANCE
AND RELIEF WITHIN THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND ITS
LICENSURE BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO
MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES I'M HERE TODAY
SPEAKING AS THE CHAIR OF DC'S
NEW MILITARY LICENSURE
COMMITTEE. WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED TO A TO ENHANCE THE
DEPARTMENT'S OVERALL ASSISTANCE
TO MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE TODAY ADDRESSING IMPORTANT
TOPIC A MILITARY SPOUSE AND
VETERAN CAREER PORTABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I COME FROM
A FAMILY WITH GENERATIONS OF
MILITARY EXPERIENCE. MY FATHER
SERVED TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN THE
AIRFORCE WITH THE MAJORITY OF
HIS CAREER SERVE THAT TRAVIS
AIR FORCE BASE NEARBY. AND MY
BROTHERS CURRENTLY STATIONED AT
CAMP PENDLETON IN SAN DIEGO.
ASSISTING MILITARY FAMILIES IS
A PASSION OF MINE. DC IS
COMMITTED TO SERVING AND
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
IT IS COMPRISED OF THIRTY SEVEN
DIFFERENT BOARDS BUREAUS A
COMMISSION IN PROGRAM THAT IT
MINISTER MORE THAN THREE
MILLION LICENSES PERMITS AND
CERTIFICATES ACROSS TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY PROFESSIONAL. IN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE TYPES.
THESE PROFESSIONS VERY FROM
DOCTORS TO DENNIS THE COURT
REPORTERS TO SMOG CHECK
TECHNICIANS NOT TO MENTION FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE COLLEGES. THE
PRIMARY MISSION OF DCA IN ITS
BOARD IN GROWTH IS CONSUMER
PROTECTION. PCA'S PROGRAMS HAVE
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO THE
PROCESSING OF LICENSURE
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED FROM
MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
SPOUSES SEEKING LICENSURE.
BILLS MANDATED REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDE POSTING DC'S MILITARY
BENEFIT INFORMATION ON THEIR
PROGRAMS WEBSITE. CAPTURING
MILITARY SERVICE INFORMATION ON
LICENSING APPLICATIONS. IN AS A
RESULT OF LEGISLATION PASSED
OVER THE YEARS THAT APARTMENT
PROBABLY OFFERS MILITARY EXCUSE
ME PROBABLY OFFERS BENEFITS TO
MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES INCLUDING EXPEDITED
LICENSING EXPEDITED LICENSING
APPLICATION PROCESSING FOR
HONORABLY DISCHARGED MILITARY
MEMBERS AND THEIR SPOUSES
RENEWAL FEE WAIVERS FOR
MILITARY MEMBERS CALLED TO
ACTIVE DUTY. AND TEMPORARY
LICENSURE. WITH DATA AVAILABLE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT SPREE
SYSTEM TO DATE THE BOARD
UTILIZING BREEZE ARE EXPEDITING
MILITARY SPOUSE APPLICATIONS ON
AVERAGE NINETEEN DAYS FASTER
THAN OTHER APPLICATIONS AND
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE ALSO ISSUED
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
RENEWAL FEE WAIVERS TO
ACTIVITIES SERVICE MEMBERS. TO
ASSIST MILITARY MEMBERS AND
THEIR SPOUSES SEEKING LICENSURE
WITH THE CA THE DEPARTMENT HAS
DEVELOPED I HAD HAS DESIGNED A
MILITARY WEB PAGE ON THE CITY'S
WEBSITE THAT WAS RECENTLY
REVAMPS BASED ON FEEDBACK
RECEIVED FROM VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE. I DESIGNATED
MILITARY EMAIL ADDRESS MILITARY
AT DC YOU DOT CA DOT GOV TO
ASSIST MILITARY MEMBERS WITH
QUESTIONS REGARDING LICENSURE
AND OUR MILITARY BENEFITS. IN
DESIGNATED STAFF AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST MILITARY MEMBERS AND
THEIR SPOUSES THROUGHOUT THE
LICENSURE PROCESS SELECT BOARDS
IN HEROES. THE DC IS OPEN TO
ADDRESSING AREAS OF NEED WHERE
I CAN PROVIDE VALUE TO MEMBERS
OF THE MILITARY AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE BUREAU OF
SECURITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES WHICH LICENSES PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS WORKS CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT THROUGH ITS WORK
FROM WARRIORS PROGRAM WHICH
HELPS LICENSE TRAIN. AN
EMPLOYEE MILITARY MEMBERS IN A
SINGLE DAY. HUNDREDS OF
MILITARY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN HELP
THROUGH THIS EFFORT OVER THE
YEARS WITH INFANTRY BEING THE
LARGEST MILITARY OCCUPATIONAL
SPECIALTY THIS IS BEEN VERY
BENEFICIAL TO THESE MEN AND
WOMEN. THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION HAS HAD
A LONG STANDING RELATIONSHIP
WITH CALVET IN REVIEWING AND
APPROVING PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
CALIFORNIA PRIVATE COLLEGES
SEEKING TO ENROLL VETERANS. BBB
EASE OFFICE OF CYNICISM VERY
LEAVE WHICH OPENED ON JULY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
PARTNERS WITH VARIOUS STATE AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES INCLUDING
COMMENTS CALIFORNIA TRANSITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN
AS CAL TOP. TO SEIZE
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS INCLUDING
STUDENT VETERANS. AFFECTED BY
THE CLOSURE OF A PRIVATE
COLLEGE ALSO ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND TO
HELP STUDENTS MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES WHEN SELECTING PRIVATE
SELECTING A COLLEGE FEES ME.
BUILDING ON THIS RELATIONSHIP
THE DEPARTMENT RECENTLY
PARTNERED WITH CALVET TO COMPLY
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS SET FORTH
IN THE SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN OFFERED BY SENATOR
VIDAK: CHAPTER EIGHTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN WHICH
PROVIDES THAT CALVET IN DCA
CONSOLE WITH ONE ANOTHER TO
INCREASE AWARENESS REGARDING
THE PROFESSIONAL LICENSING
BENEFITS. AVAILABLE TO VETERANS
AND THEIR SPOUSES. PCA'S
MILITARY BENEFIT INFORMATION IS
NOW AVAILABLE I EXCUSE ME IS
NOW INCLUDED IN THE STANDING
PRESENTATION ACCOUNT TOP STOP
PRESENT TO DO CHARGING SERVICE
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHILE WE ARE PROUD OF OUR
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO ASSIST
MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
SPOUSES WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S ALWAYS OPPORTUNITY FOR
IMPROVEMENT. CURRENTLY NOT ALL
THE C. PROGRAMS RECOGNIZE
LICENSES FROM OTHER STATES AS A
MEANS FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BEGIN
WORKING IN CALIFORNIA UPON
ARRIVAL OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
RECIPROCITY. THIS COULD BE DUE
TO A VARIETY OF REASONS
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT MANY
PROGRAMS HAVE CALIFORNIA'S
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
MORE STRINGENT. THAN THOSE IN
OTHER STATES. LICENSING
RECIPROCITY MAY ALSO BE
DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE GIVEN THE
UNIQUE NATURE OF THE PROGRAM'S
WITHIN DCA AND THE LOCATIONS
THAT THEY LET ME LICENSE. A
PROGRAM SPECIFIC APPROACH TO
MORTGAGE MAY BE MORE EFFECTIVE
IN ACHIEVING LICENSE
PORTABILITY. PRIVATE DEPARTMENT
WIDE INITIATIVES ARE OFTEN
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT CHANGES
HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVES
FOCUSING ON SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES
OR LICENSE TYPE ALLOWS FOR THE
MAXIMUM BENEFIT TO MILITARY
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES IF
THERE ARE PROBLEMS ARE BARRIERS
WE ENCOURAGE THE MILITARY
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES. TO
CONTACT THE DEPARTMENT IDENTIFY
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS WE HAVE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE AND ARE AWARE THAT
THAT LICENSE PORTABILITY IS ONE
OF THEIR TOP INTERESTS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
COLLABORATION WITH THEIR
DEPARTMENT. OUR DEPARTMENT
REMAINS COMMITTED TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAW ASSISTING
MILITARY MEMBERS AND THEIR
SPOUSES WITH OBTAINING
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA. WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT OKAY LET'S
LET'S WAIT FOR FROM ONE TO
PRESENT IT WILL HAVE A
DISCUSSION WHEN X. YOU'RE FROM
ERIN SCHOOL BALL FROM OUR CTC.
THANK YOU I'M AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH MANY MEMBERS FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT
TEACHER LICENSING AND THE
BENEFITS WE HAVE FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES. I'M SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND THE LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION SB TOTAL NINE
CALIFORNIA HAS REALLY PUSH TO
REDUCE THE BARRIERS FOR OUT OF
STATE PREPARED EDUCATORS ACROSS
ALL STATES. SO AT THIS POINT
CALIFORNIA HAS A TWO TIERED
CREDENTIALING SYSTEM. THE
MINIMAL REQUIREMENTS FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE REGARDLESS WHETHER
THEY'RE MILITARY SPOUSE OR NOT
IS A BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM
REGIONALLY ACCREDITED
INSTITUTION. A FINGERPRINT
CLEARANCE AND A WRIST
RECIPROCAL OUT OF STATE
TEACHING LICENSE SO THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS AN
INDIVIDUAL DOES NEED TO
COMPLETE WITHIN ONE TO FIVE
YEARS OF THEIR INITIAL
LICENSING IN ORDER TO OBTAIN
THE SECOND YOUR CREDENTIAL
WHICH IS THE CLEAR CREDENTIAL.
BUT IT JUST KIND OF WANT TO
LEAVE OUT FOUNDATION AS WE TALK
ABOUT SOME MORE SPECIFIC
BENEFITS THAT THE COMMISSION
OFFERS FOR MILITARY SPOUSES. SO
WE HAVE AT THREE MAIN BENEFITS
THAT WE HAVE FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES A LOT OF WHICH KELLY
SPOKE TO YOU EARLIER AROUND THE
APPLICATION PROCESSING FEE AND
THE EXPEDITING ABOUT LOCATIONS
WE DO YOU OFFER THE- MILITARY
SPOUSE FEE WAIVER AND THAT WAS
THE FIRST ITEM I MET TALK
ABOUT. ON THAT WAS EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TEN. AND AB AT SEVEN NINETY
FOUR DIRECTED THE COMMISSION TO
WAIVE THE INITIAL PROCESSING
FEE FOR MILITARY SPOUSES IF
THEY RELOCATE TO CALIFORNIA
BASED ON ANY RELOCATION ORDERS
FROM ANY UNITED STATES ARMED
FORCES. SO THIS IS AVAILABLE
FOR A SPOUSE'S INITIAL TEACHING
CREDENTIAL BUT THE INITIAL
TEACHING CREDENTIAL OF ANY TYPE
OFTEN MILITARY SPOUSES ARE
CREDENTIALED IN MULTIPLE AREAS
THEY MIGHT BE CREDENTIALED IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN GENERAL
EDUCATION. SO WOULD BE FOR THE
INITIAL CREDENTIAL TYPE EITHER
SPECIAL EDUCATION OR AN INITIAL
GENERAL EDUCATION CREDENTIAL.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN WE'VE
HAD NEARLY A THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS UTILIZE THIS FEE
WAIVER. AND THAT'S ABOUT A
LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS PER YEAR COMING IN
TO OBTAIN THIS FEE WAIVER. I'M
RECENTLY AND TWO THOUSAND
EFFECTIVE JAN FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A. B. TWO
TWENTY SIX RECTOR THE
COMMISSION TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESSING A MILITARY SPOUSE
APPLICATIONS IF THEY'RE COMING
IN BASED ON OUT OF STATE
PREPARATION. THE COMMISSION HAS
A FIFTY BUSINESS STATE MANDATED
PROCESSING REQUIREMENT I'M SO
WE HAVE FIFTY BUSINESS DAYS TO
PROCESS AN APPLICATION THAT
COMES SAID OFTENTIMES WERE WELL
BELOW THAT FIFTY BUSINESS DAY
PROCESSING BUT SOMETIMES IN THE
BUSY SEASON WE CAN HIT. UP TO
FIFTY BUSINESS DAYS FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE ARE REQUIRED TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESSING OF THE APPLICATION
AND GIVE THEM A DETERMINATION
ON THEIR APPLICATION WITHIN
SEVEN DAYS OF US PHYSICALLY
RECEIVING THAT APPLICATION. SO
IF THE INDIVIDUAL QUALIFIES
BASED ON THE MATERIAL SUBMITTED
THE APPLICATION WE'RE GONNA
GRANT APPLICATION WITHIN SEVEN
DAYS OF RECEIPT. IF THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO BE
PROVIDED TO US WE'RE GONNA GET
THEM THAT LETTER IN WRITING
VERIFYING THAT WE'VE PROCESS
THEIR APPLICATION AND TELLING
THEM EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED FROM
THEM. TO CONTINUE PROCESSING SO
THAT IS A VERY RECENT CHANGE
AND LEGISLATION THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING AS WE SPEAK. AND
THEN THE LAST. SECTION A STATUE
THAT I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR VETERANS OR
ACTIVE MILITARY SERVICE.
MEMBERS WHO HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL OR PERMIT. AND THESE
INDIVIDUALS IF THEY ARE CALLED
OUT ON FOR ACTIVE DUTY THEIR
DOCUMENT IS. REMAIN IN EFFECT
UNTIL SIX MONTHS PASS A BEAR
DISCHARGE THEIR THEIR
DISCHARGED FROM SERVICE SO
THEIR CREDENTIAL WOULD NOT
EXPIRE IT WOULD REMAIN IN
EFFECT THEY WOULD CONTACT THEIR
LOCAL EMPLOYING AGENCY. TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR EMPLOYER
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR DOCUMENT
REMAINS IN EFFECT AND ALSO WITH
THE COMMISSION WE WOULD
MAINTAIN THE VALIDITY OF THEIR
DOCUMENT UP TO SIX MONTHS.
AFTER THEIR DISCHARGE FROM
SERVICE IT'S A REALLY THOSE
THREE MAIN STATUTORY AREAS ARE
WHERE WE HAVE THE MILITARY
BENEFITS WE ARE CONSTANTLY
STRIVING TO IDENTIFY OTHER
AREAS WHERE WE CAN REDUCE THE
BARRIERS FOR ALL HONESTY
APPLICANTS AND THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY INCLUDING AFFECT
MILITARY SPOUSES. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND FINALLY EVELYN
AND WITH THE LAWYERS. I A
MILLION YES IS FOR THE STATE
BAR. GOOD AFTERNOON HAD CHAIRS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M A
MEANING AS I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF ADMISSIONS AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR. AND I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT A PROGRAM
THAT WE'VE RECENTLY IMPLEMENTED
FOR US MILITARY SPOUSES SO THIS
IS A REGISTERED RELEASED
MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY
PROGRAM WHICH IS A SPECIAL
ADMISSIONS PROGRAM. ALLOWING A
LICENSING OF FOR A MILITARY
SPOUSE ATTORNEYS. SO THE
IMPETUS FOR THIS PROGRAM
STARTED WITH. EIGHT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STRATEGIC
PLAN GOAL WHICH ARE DIRECTED
STAFF TO LOOK AT OUR SPECIAL
ADMISSIONS RULES TO DETERMINE
IF THERE WAS A WAY TO
FACILITATE A SPECIAL EDITIONS
AND TO INCREASE ACCESS TO LEGAL
SERVICES AND A THAT REQUIRE
THAT WE LOOK AT OUR THREE
SEPARATE PROGRAMS SO WE HAVE
THREE SPECIAL ADMISSIONS
PROGRAMS ARE FIRST IS THE
REGISTERED IN HOUSE COUNSEL
WHICH HAS BEEN IN THE FACT. OF
FOR SOME TIME AS WELL AS OUR
REGISTER LEGAL SERVICES
ATTORNEY THESE PROGRAMS ALLOW
TEMPORARY LICENSING FOR OF OUT
OF STATE OF ATTORNEYS TO COME
TO CALIFORNIA PRACTICE WITHOUT
HAVING TO TAKE THE BAR EXAM.
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS SO WE
WERE ABLE TO USE THOSE PROGRAMS
TO LOOK AT REGISTERED OF
MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY. SO
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
MILITARY SPOUSES JD NETWORK
WITH ESTABLISHED OF TO AIDS
SPOUSES OF MILITARY A SERVICE
MEMBERS IN FINDING EMPLOYMENT.
AS ATTORNEYS IN THE STATE OR
TERRITORY TO WHICH THEY'RE
ACTIVE MILITARY SPOUSES BEEN
ASSIGNED SO THEY'RE CURRENTLY
THIRTY ONE STATES IN CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THEM THAT HAVE
INCORPORATED A SPECIAL
ADMISSIONS POLICY. AND SO. WE
ARE ADOPTED THIS RULE ON MARCH
FIRST TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IT
WENT INTO A FACT SPECIFICALLY
WHAT OF THE PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA RULE NINETY NINE
POINT FOUR POINT ONE DOES. IS
IT ALLOWS ACTIVE ATTORNEYS IN
GOOD STANDING IN A U. S.
THERE'S A STATE OR A U. S.
JURISDICTION WHO MUST BE
MARRIED TO OR IN A CIVIL UNION
WITH. A BE A REGISTERED
DOMESTIC PARTNER OF A SERVICE
MEMBER EXCEPT THAT THE ATTORNEY
MAY CONTINUE TO PRACTICE AS A
REGISTERED A MILITARY SPOTS
ATTORNEY FOR ONE YEAR AFTER THE
TERM. THAT MARRIAGE. IN ORDER
MESSICK PARTNERSHIP UNDER IN
CALIFORNIA WE INSURE THAT THE
DEFINITION OF SPOUSE CONFORMS
TO CALIFORNIA LOST SO THAT
CIVIL UNIONS AND DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIPS WERE INCLUDED. WE
ALSO DISTINGUISHED IN THE RULE
THERE WAS A MODEL RULE THAT
WAS. PROVIDED BY THE J. D.
NETWORK WE WANTED TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATIVE SUSPENSIONS AND
DISCIPLINARY MISCONDUCT.
BECAUSE OF THE IN THE RULE IN
THE MODEL RULE THERE WAS A
THERE WAS A CLEAR DISTINCTION
BETWEEN ADMINISTRATIVE
SUSPENSIONS WHICH COULD INCLUDE
SUSPENSIONS AS A RESULT OF NOT
PAYING FEES SO WE DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE A BARRIER FOR
MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEYS. WE
ALSO INSURE THAT THE RULE
ACCOMMODATES MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS
TO OF FOR THE BAR EXAM. SO IF
ANYBODY HAS TAKEN THE BAR EXAM
FIVE YEARS PRIOR IT NOT PASSED
YOU NOT BE OF ELIGIBLE FOR A
MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY.
PROGRAM HOWEVER ONCE YOU BECOME
A MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY. NO
ATTEMPT AT THE BAR EXAM WHETHER
YOU PASS OR FAIL WILL IMPACT
THAT SO WE WANTED TO. ENSURE
THAT THE BAR EXAM WOULD NOT BE
AN IMPEDIMENT TO THE OF
BECOMING AN ATTORNEY CALIFORNIA
WE ALSO ADDED LANGUAGE IN THE
RULE TO ENCOURAGE PRO BONO SO
THAT SOMEONE. WHO IS A MILITARY
SPOUSE ATTORNEY COULD ALSO
PROVIDE PRO BONO SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE INITIALLY
RECEIVED ABOUT THE RULE. IS
THAT THERE IS A SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENT TO THE RULE YOU
NEED TO BE SUPERVISED BY ADULTS
ACTIVE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY. AND
SO THE US MILITARY SPOUSE G. D.
NETWORK AND TOLD US THAT OR
PROVIDE FEEDBACK THAT THE
SUPERVISION PER COMPONENT COULD
HINDER SOMEBODY'S ABILITY TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT CALIFORNIA. AND
IT MIGHT BE TOO ONEROUS FOR
SOMEBODY TO EMPLOY A AN
ATTORNEY UNDER THOSE
CONDITIONS. SOME OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE ALSO RECEIVED
FROM THE. THIS IS THE
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE
OF PROVIDED FEEDBACK LETTING US
KNOW THAT SUPERVISION WAS NOT
OVERLY BURDENSOME AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT A PART OF PUBLIC
PROTECTION. THERE WAS ALSO
CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER THE. THE
RULES I HAD A DISPARATE IMPACT
ON IT WOMEN ATTORNEYS THAT IS
IF THEY WOULD LOSE REGISTRATION
OF THROUGH OF SEPARATION OR
DISSOLUTION OF THAT
PARTNERSHIP. WE'VE ADDED
LANGUAGE TO EASE SOME OF THAT
SO THAT WE YOU COULD AT THE
STATE WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER THIS PROGRAM AT LEAST ONE
YEAR AFTER THE DISSOLUTION. IN
TERMS OF THE SUPERVISION THE
BOARD IS COMMITTED TO LOOKING
AT A REVISITING THIS PART
COMPONENT OF THE RULES TWO
YEARS AFTER IMPLEMENTATION. TO
ENSURE THAT WE STILL CARRY OUT
PUBLIC PROTECTION BUT ALSO THAT
THE PROGRAM IS A FISSION AND IS
CARRIED OUT WITH IN THE SPIRIT
OF THE LAW WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
A SPECIAL ADMISSIONS OR ENTRY
PASS. MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEYS.
LASTLY THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WE
HAVE ENROLLED SO THE ROLE WENT
INTO A FACT. IN A MARCH OF THIS
YEAR AND WE HAVE TO ACTIVE
APPLICANTS AND ONE PENDING SO
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO INCREASE
OUR ENROLLMENT. OKAY. I GUESS
ONE WOULD DISAGREE A QUICK
QUESTION FOR THIS HOW DO WE
EVALUATE YEAH THESE FIRST TWO
ARGUMENTS RIGHT ONE SAYS THAT
IT IT IS TOO ONEROUS THE OTHER
ONE SAYS IT ISN'T. IS THE ISSUE
OF BEING IMPORTANT FOR PUBLIC
PROTECTION THAT IF SOMEONE IS
LICENSE IN ANOTHER STATE. THE
STEEP ARE HERE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE ADEQUATE
CONTROL OVER THE DISCIPLINARY
RECORD. IS THAT THE BIG CONCERN
I THINK THE CONCERN IS THE OF
SETTING THEMSELVES IN COURT
WITHOUT HAVING SOME SUPPORT SO
OF THE RULE ITSELF WAS MODELED
AFTER REGISTERED IN HOUSE
COUNSEL UNDER BRIDGES JR A
LEGAL AID ATTORNEY OF RULES AND
ONE OF THOSE SO READ REGISTER
LEGAL AID ATTORNEY DO NOT
REPRESENT ANYBODY IN COURT
REGISTERED IN HOUSE COUNSEL TO
YOU UNDER DIRECT SUPERVISION SO
THAT FOR EXAMPLE PROCEEDINGS
AND BRIEFS PLEADINGS NEED TO BE
SIGNED BY A SUPER SIR WE ADDED
THAT. THE PUBLIC PROTECTION IN
THIS WHAT I WANT TO DO I'M
PROVIDE YOU WAS OF A DIFFERENT
UP PERSPECTIVES LOT OF SURFACED
AS WE WERE PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER. RIGHT IS I GUESS WHAT
I'M I'M ALWAYS A LITTLE. I A.
YOU KNOW IN A LOT OF THESE
LESSER CONVERSATIONS THERE'S
ALWAYS THIS CONVERSATION A
PUBLIC PROTECTION. AND I
HAVEN'T. THE LITTLE BIT OF A
LEASE THE DATE I'VE SEEN SOME
OF ITS SHARED IN THIS PACKAGE
I'D SUGGEST THAT THE IDEA THAT
THERE IS SOME SORT OF. ENORMOUS
DIFFERENCE AND QUALITY OF THE
PROFESSIONALS FROM ONE STATE TO
ANOTHER. IS A PRETTY DUBIOUS
NOW THERE ARE ISSUES THAT COME
INTO PLAY WITH THEIR CARS TO
ACCOUNTABILITY RIGHT SO IF YOU
ARE IF YOU HAVE YOUR LICENSE
WITH ONE STATE. HI AND THE
OTHER STATE WHERE YOU'RE NOT
PRACTICING DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
ANY CONTROL OVER YOUR
DISCIPLINARY RECORD OR ANY KIND
OF LIKE. CONTROL OVER
RESTRICTING YOUR ABILITY TO
WORK IN THAT SECOND STATE BASED
ON THINGS THAT YOU DO WRONG
THEN THAT THERE'S A REAL
PROBLEM THERE. AND I CAN TALK
TO BE AN AREA OF SOME TENSION
WITH REGARDS TO. TO LICENSOR
PORTABILITY BUT I GUESS I WAS
TRYING TO PARTS OF PARLIAMENT
WHAT YOU WHAT YOU WHAT WHAT
WHAT THE CCHA MATT WHEN THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PUBLIC PROTECTION
THEIR CROWDS TO. SUPERVISION
WELL IT'S ONE OF THE MISSIONS
OF THE STATE BAR IS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC PROTECTION FOR ANYBODY
ACCESSING A LEGAL SERVICES WE
ALSO DID SOME ANALYSIS ON IN
TERMS OF LICENSING OF WHAT
OTHER JURISDICTION'S DOING IN
TERMS OF SUPERVISION FOR
MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEYS I
THINK THERE ARE AT LEAST ELEVEN
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE THAT
COMPONENT IS A REQUIREMENT. AS
WELL AS MENTORING COMPONENT BUT
IT WAS A LOT THERE WE DID
GATHER A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AROUND THAT TOPIC ITSELF WHICH
IS WHY THE BOARD IS A COMMITTED
TO REVISITING THIS ISSUE SO I'M
TWO YEARS DOWN THE LINE WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT WHAT KIND OF.
IMPACT IT HAS LIKE IN TERMS OF
ACCESSIBILITY FOR MILITARY
SPOUSE ATTORNEYS. AS WELL AS
DISTANT IMPACT THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING. NOW I KNOW LAW HAS
ITS OWN UNIQUE SET OF
CHALLENGES BECAUSE OF HOW
DIFFERENT. STATE LAWS. CAN BE
IN AND THE IMPACTS OF
PROCEDURES AFTER BUT. I WANTED
TO ALSO ASK YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
THIS REPORT THAT CAME OUT OF
UNIVERSITY MINISTERING TO THE
REACH REPORT THAT IS ON THE
MEMBERS YOU CAN SEE ON. TAB
SEVEN. OF YOUR BOOKLETS AND IT
COMES OUT THEY DID A REPORTING
ON EVERY STATE IN THE COUNTRY
LOOKING AT LEGISLATION LOOKING
AT THE STATE OF PLAY THEY
LOOKED AT VARIOUS. HI.
DIFFERENT AREAS OF LICENSURE IN
ONE OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS AT
THE END. WITH A FREE FUTURE
EFFORTS COULD ADVOCATE TO
MODIFY OUR EXISTING LEGISLATION
AB ONE EIGHTY SIX AND IN
NINETEEN OH FOUR TO READ
OCCUPATIONAL BOARD SHALL ALLOW
SHELL ALLOW LICENSURE BY
ENDORSEMENT FOR SPOUSES NOW.
YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S A JUST
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD JUST
MEAN THAT LITERALLY. A LICENSE
FROM ANOTHER STATE WOULD BE
IMMEDIATE WOULD BE IMMEDIATELY
PORTABLE WITH NO QUESTIONS
ASKED. I HAVE ONE MORE SLIDE
THAT KIND OF EXPLAINS THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT IT. YES SO
THAT ONE ENDORSEMENT ONE EIGHTY
SIX IS TEMPORARY LICENSE SO WE
ARE I BELIEVE THAT'S THE ONE
THAT IS A VERY LICENSURE FOR
NINE PROGRAMS. MIA IF THERE. OF
SO WHAT WE'RE KIND OF LOOKING
AT IS. TAKING NINE AND
EXPANDING IT RECOMMENDING THAT
THAT STATES REALLY LOOK AT
EXPANDING THAT THAT KIND OF
POLICY WHICH IS BASICALLY AN
EXTENDED TEMPORARY LICENSE THAT
WOULD GIVE THAT WOULD DO TWO
THINGS. BUT STILL TEMPORARY YES
IT'S STILL A WELL AS FAR AS THE
AT ONE EIGHTY SIX THAT WE'RE
NOT IN THE WITH WITH THE REDS
THIS RECOMMENDATION THAT THAT
IS HERE THIS IDEA OF LICENSURE
BY ENDORSEMENT OKAY SO THE
LICENSURE BY ENDORSEMENT THOUGH
IS SO WE KIND OF HAVE TO ASK
FLEMING CAM BACK CHECK A LITTLE
BIT. SO WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SOME
STATES THAT HAVE EXPANDED
BASICALLY LICENSURE BY
ENDORSEMENT TO THIS TERM OF
RECOGNITION SO WE WENT FROM.
THIS FROM LOOKING AT IT FROM A
WRIST RECIPROCITY STANDPOINT
BECAUSE. REST OF RECIPROCITY
INFERS THAT THERE'S A- MUTUAL
AGREEMENT BETWEEN PARTIES WHICH
WE'RE NOT REALLY LOOKING AT
RECIPROCITY WHEN WE'RE ASKING
FOR EXPANSION OF LICENSURE BY
ENDORSEMENT TO IN BASICALLY
BECOMING LICENSURE BY
RECOGNITION ARIZONA AND
RECENTLY PASSED A BILL H. B.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY NINE THAT
ALREADY WAS AVAILABLE FOR
SPOUSES THEY ACTUALLY DID THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THEY EXPANDED AND AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WAS ALREADY
FOR SPOUSES TO THEIR GENERAL
POPULATION SO NOW ANYONE COMING
INTO ARIZONA WITH THE LICENSE
OUT OF STATE. HAS THEIR FINGER
PRINTING AND BACKGROUND CHECK
DONE. THE I'M PAY THE FEE AND
THEN DATE ESSENTIALLY GET AN
ARIZONA LICENSE WITH BASICALLY
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE PREVIOUS
STATE STATES LICENSE SHOWS THAT
THEY ARE QUALIFIED TO PERFORM
THAT POSITION THAT JOB. AND SO
ARIZONA STAMPS THEIR THEIR
THEIR LICENSE AND THEY GET A
LICENSURE BY RECOGNITION
FLORIDA DOES THAT TOO AND I
AWAY ACTUALLY DOES SOMETHING
SIMILAR BUT JUST FOR TEACHERS
SO. THAT THE ENDORSEMENT PIECE
OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
ASKING STATES TO LOOK AT THOSE
STATES. GET THOSE OTHER THOSE
OTHER MODELS AND AT LEAST FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT MILITARY SPOUSES MOVE
EVERY THREE TO FOUR YEARS BY
THE TIME THEY GO THROUGH ALL
THIS PROCESSING OF. THIS ALL
ALL THIS PROCESS OF. OF GETTING
AFFIDAVITS GETTING I
ENDORSEMENTS FROM THEIR
PREVIOUS EMPLOYERS GETTING ALL
THEIR TRANSCRIPTS THEN HAVING
THE BOARDS. SPEND SOME TIME
EVALUATING WHETHER IT'S
SUBSTANTIALLY EQUIVALENT WHICH
IS USUALLY. SUBSTANTIALLY
EQUIVALENT IS THE EASE. AT ST.
SINCE BY ENDORSEMENTS THAT'S
CAUSING THE UNDERLYING ISSUE
FOR SPOUSES IS THAT THERE'S AN
EVALUATION PROCESS WHERE
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE OR OTHER
STATES BUT CALIFORNIAN THIS
EXAMPLE WOULD LOOK AT. ALL THE
COURSE WORK ALL OF THE
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY EVERYTHING
AND THEN MAKE A DETERMINATION
IF THEY GET A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE SO THERE'S THIS AND
THIS DELAY CAUSED BY HAVING TO.
SUBMIT ALL THOSE DOCUMENTS THEN
WAIT FOR THE AT THE EVALUATION
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR A LICENSURE
BY ENDORSEMENT OR RECOGNITION
WITHOUT. THIS LONG DRAWN OUT
PROCESS OF EVALUATION OF STEP
SUBSTANTIAL AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR IT JUST A IN PERPETUITY OR
FOR THE TIME THAT THEY ARE
STATE THAT THERE THERE'S A
HOUSES THE STATION. YES
CALIFORNIA SO THERE'S DIFFERENT
MODELS AT DIFFERENT STATES DUE
TO WE DON'T TELL THE STATE'S
WHAT TO DO BUT WE WE'VE LOOKED
AT A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
MODELS AND I THINK FOR
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS KIND OF THE
THIS IS ONE FRAMEWORK. NUMBER
ONE PROVIDE EXTENDED TEMPORARY
LICENSE FOR MILITARY SPOUSES SO
THAT THEY CAN GET A LICENSE
WITH THEIR- FINGER PRINTING AND
A BACKGROUND CHECK AND THEY'RE
ON A VERIFICATION THAT THEIR
LICENSES GOOD IN GOOD STANDING.
THAT THEY WOULD FILL OUT THE%
APPLICATION BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT APPLICATION EXPEDITED GET
THEIR LICENSE AND THEN BE
PROVIDED A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME TO PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY
SUBSTANTIATING DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S FOR IF THEY WANT A FULL
ENDORSEMENT BUT IF THEY DON'T
WANT A FULL ENDORSEMENT AND
THEY JUST WANT TO WORK WHILE
THEY'RE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
TWO TO THREE YEARS WE'RE ALSO
ASKING STATES TO. CONSIDER JUST
A LONG JUST A TEMPER EXTENDED
TEMPORARY LICENSE THROUGH THE
PERIOD OF TIME THAT THEY'RE
HERE. NOW THEY. DECIDE TO STAY
LONGER THAN THEY WOULD NEED TO
GO THROUGH A PROCESS OF.
CONVERTING THEIR LICENSE INTO A
FULL CALIFORNIA LICENSE. I
GUESS MY QUESTION I'M- TO MISS
SCHOOL AND MISS NEW YES IS WHAT
WOULD BE. WHAT'S YOUR REACTION
TO THAT SORT OF PROPOSAL DOES
THAT SOUND. REASONABLE DO A
BALL IN YOUR RESPECTIVE
PROFESSIONS. AM I THINK THE WE
ARE HALFWAY THERE ALREADY I
THINK THAT OUR INITIAL
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS FOR
TEACHING. IS A DOT THEY HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FOR
REGIONALLY ACCREDITED COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY. THAT THEY HAVE
THE FINGERPRINT CLEARANCE AND
THAT THE HAVE THAT COMPARABLE
OUT OF STATE LICENSE SO I THINK
THE ONLY ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT
THAT WE HAVE FOR INITIAL
LICENSURE IS THAT BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD.
THE COMMISSION WOULD CONSIDER
REMOVAL ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THAT
IS A STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS PREPARED THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREE YEAH I'M IT'S
NOT OFTEN THAT WE SEE
INDIVIDUALS COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
BACHELOR'S DEGREE THOUGH THAT'S
A VERY VERY RARE. HOWEVER WE
ARE CEASING SOME INTERESTING
THINGS HAPPENING OUT OF STATE
WITH CONCERNS FOR TEACHER
SHORTAGES SO THERE ARE SOME
VERY INTERESTING LICENSURE
PATHWAYS THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED RIGHT NOW THAT COULD
VERY WELL RESULT IN INDIVIDUALS
COMING IN WITHOUT A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE BUT AGAIN THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN OFTEN I THINK IT IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU SPOKE TO
REGARDING. MILITARY SPOUSES WAY
TO COME IN FOR JUST TWO YEARS
AND SERVING A TEMPORARY
CAPACITY I'M IS A REALLY
INTERESTING THOUGHT THAT I'M
DEFINITELY GOING TO TAKE BACK
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION.
TEACHING PERMIT REQUIRES A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES PASSAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA BASIC SKILLS EXAM.
INDIVIDUALS CAN USE AN EXAM
FROM OUT OF STATE IF THEY'VE
TAKEN A COMPARABLE BASIC SKILLS
EXAM THAT COVERS READING
WRITING AND MATHEMATICS. BUT IF
THE STATE DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
TYPE OF EXAM THAN AN INDIVIDUAL
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE THAT SEE
BEST EXAM IN ORDER TO. EARNED
THAT SUBSTITUTE TEACHING PERMIT
IF THEY JUST WANT TO COME IN
AND BE A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER.
I'M SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD LOOK AT
TO SEE WHERE WE COULD MAKE SOME
CONCESSIONS THERE AND POSSIBLY
DO SOME TYPE OF BASIC SKILLS
EXAM WEAVER OR SOMETHING FOR
THESE MILITARY SPOUSES. I WENT
OUT. AND FOR THE STATE BAR WE
DON'T HAVE RECIPROCITY IS THAT
RECIPROCITY PROGRAM OUTSIDE A
MILITARY SPOUSE FAMILIES SHOW
OF WE HAVE A UNIQUE SET UP IN
TERMS OF WE DON'T USE FOR
EXAMPLE THE UNIFORMED BARK THE
UNIFORM BAR EXAM WHICH A LOT OF
STATES DO YOU AND ALLOW
RECIPROCITY FOR THAT REASON
HOWEVER IN TERMS OF AN EXTENDED
TEMPORARY LICENSE. BEDS I THINK
WERE PARTIALLY THERE WITH OUR
CURRENT PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE A
DESPITE THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH FINGERPRINT
BACKGROUND CHECK IN THE FORM OF
THE MORAL CHARACTER
INVESTIGATION THAT OCCURS
YOU'RE STILL ALLOWED TO WORK
WHILE THAT A FORMAL PROCESSOR
INVESTIGATION IS HAPPENING SO
IN TERMS OF THE TEMPER
LICENSING I THINK THAT'S NOT AN
IMPEDIMENT. OKAY I WANT I WANT
ONE FINAL QUESTION I WANT TO GO
TO CHAIR A GLAZER AND THAT IS
THIS ISSUE SO ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT CAME UP AT THE COUNCIL
STATE GOVERNMENTS. I'M KIND OF
ONE DAY I DID A FULL DAY
SESSION ON THIS THIS THIS ISSUE
OF LICENSURE IS VERY
INTERESTING. ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT THAT THAT STATES CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IS
DISCIPLINARY RECORDS. AND WHO
HOLD THOSE RECORDS HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S-
ACCOUNTABILITY OF SOMEONE BEING
A BEHAVES BADLY IN ONE STATE
THAT THERE ARE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY OTHER STATES AND
WE'RE NOT GONNA PASSING ON
PROBLEMS. AND THIS IS A COURSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A MINUSCULE
PORTION OF CERTAINLY THE
MILITARY SPOUSE POPULATION BUT
IT'S THE KIND OF THING THEY CAN
GET ALL OF OUR EFFORTS HUNG UP.
I AND ONE OF THINGS I ASK YOUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE NORTHWEST
WAS. ON BECAUSE THEY'RE SUCH.
IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE YOU'VE
FOLKS MOVING AROUND SO MUCH.
MAYBE THE DEPARTMENT DEFENSE
OUGHT TO BE THE KEEPERS OF THE
DATE OF THE DISCIPLINARY
DATABASE. SO AS TO BE ABLE TO
EXPEDITE. I YOU TO TRANSFER ALL
TO. THE CREDENTIAL OURS. SO
THAT YOU'LL ALL HAVE YOU KNOW
COME A CREDIBLE PACKET TO LOOK
AT IF THEY'RE IN A TO DO TO
ENSURE THAT. THAT THAT THAT
SOMEONE DOES NOT HAVE A
DISCIPLINARY RECORD IN ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY WHERE
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
DUDE. THE THIRD THIRD JUST.
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN ANSWERS
ASSOCIATED THAT IT MAY ACTUALLY
BE. AN APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR
THIS TO BE HOUSE AFTER YOU.
ANYWAY I'D LOVE TO SEE IF YOU
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK INTO THAT
OF LAST MONTH AND IF YOU ANY
THOUGHTS ON THAT ISSUE. I
REMEMBER THAT QUESTION. OKAY SO
I THINK TWO THINGS THOUGH THAT
WE WE'RE LOOKING AT IS AND ONE
IS THAT. THERE IS IT IS FAR AS
DISCIPLINARY RECORDS AND
VERIFYING. THAT KIND OF THING I
THINK. THAT ISN'T REALLY THE
PROBLEM THAT'S ALREADY IN PLACE
SO IF WITH MILITARY SPOUSE
COMES THE CALIFORNIA AND SAYS I
HAVE A LICENSE IN ARIZONA
CALIFORNIA THAT BOARD. CAN
CALLED THE BOARD AND THERE'S ON
AND FIND OUT THAT SEE THAT'S
THE EASY PART. THE OTHER PIECES
THAT AS FAR AS DISCIPLINE GOES.
WE HAVE PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT SPOUSES BUT WE WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO HAVE ANY SORT OF
TRACKING BECAUSE THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY WORK FOR DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE. SO YOU KNOW I'M SAYING
WE WERE KIND OF IN THIS SPACE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO. SUPPORT
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUPPORTING THE SERVICE MEMBER
WHO'S WHO'S SERVING BUT WE
CAN'T. THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT. HAS SOARED
OR IS IT IS ASKING THE TO THE
EXTENT THIS HAS BECOME A
PROBLEM I AN INMATE MAYBE IT
WAS OVERSTATED THE CONFERENCE.
I WAS WHAT MAYBE THEY'LL BE
LIKE AN OPT IN OR SOMETHING
WHERE WHERE WHERE THE SPOUSE
WITH WOULD VOLUNTARILY. YOU
KNOW. AUTHORIZED DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE TO KIND OF. BE THE
KEEPER OF THE- PACKAGE WE HAVE
SO THAT SO THAT SO AS TO BE
ABLE TO EXPEDITE. STATE BY
STATE PORTABILITY I DON'T KNOW
I. SO I THINK THAT AGAIN I
THINK THAT THE MAIN ISSUE ISN'T
SO ISN'T VERIFYING THEIR
PREVIOUS THAT BECAUSE THAT'S ON
THAT'S ON THE BOARD. TYPICALLY
THEY THEY HAVE A PROCESS FOR
VERIFYING THAT THE PERSONS
ASIDE. AS PREVIOUS THE-
CERTIFICATION OR OR WHAT HAVE
YOU. AS FAR AS KIND OF A PORTAL
FOR HOLDING THEIR PREVIOUS SIX
ALL OF THEIR PREVIOUS RECORDS.
THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WOULD BE BENEFICIAL AND
MAY BE LOOKED AT. HOWEVER ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE ALSO SAY
IS THAT. EVERY STATE IS SO
DIFFERENT WITH THEIR
REQUIREMENTS AND THEIR
ENDORSEMENT PROCESS THAT
SPOUSES DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO
ANTICIPATE AS FAR AS WHAT THEY
NEED TO PROVIDE. SO THERE'S
ALWAYS GOING TO BE KIND OF THAT
UNKNOWN. OKAY WITH WITH I KNEW
WHAT CALIFORNIA EXPECTED NOW
WHAT IS FLORIDA EXPECT WHAT IS
VERGING EXPECTS SO. I JUST
THINK THAT THE- THE
DIFFERENCES. THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO MITIGATE
TWO IS THE IS JUST TRYING TO.
RESOLVE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT HAPPEN WHEN YOU HAVE STATE
TO STATE DIFFERENCES. AND WHICH
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE WE
WHEN I WENT ON THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT BUT JUST TRYING TO
MITIGATE THAT. SO I DON'T HAVE
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AND
THAT'S NOT THERE. MAY BE SOME
SORT OF PORTAL WOULD HELP
SPOUSES. I DON'T KNOW THEY THE
VISIBILITY OF THE DOD PROVIDING
THAT BUT I DON'T TO SOMEBODY.
THE FIVE POINT YOU KNOW THAT
YES INDEED IN TALKING WITH
RADIO. SERIES YOU'RE IN CLOSE
TOUCH WITH THE STANCE BUT TO
THE EXTENT OF THAT CAME UP. AT
THE CONFERENCE AS AN ISSUE I
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
CONTACT THAT THEY DID WITH
REGARD TO NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
THAT I THINK WHAT TWELVE FIFTY
STATES HAVE JOINED. I'M DAVE
DAVE. YOU KNOW THEIR RIGHT TO
THEIR THEIR SOME OF THOSE
CONTACTS THEY HAVE THEY'VE
THEY'VE THEY'VE CREATED SOME
SORT OF PORTAL FOR DISCIPLINARY
RECORDS IN YES AND I THINK
THAT'S ITS I DIE WILL I'M GLAD
THAT I CAN I SAY GRAY OFF OF
THAT BECAUSE MY FINAL POINT I
WANTED TO SAY IS DEPARTMENT
OFFENSES ACTUALLY. THEY'RE
REINVENTING LICENSING
PORTABILITY BY PROVIDING HOME
STATE LICENSEES WITH PRIVILEGES
TO PRACTICE AND OTHER MEMBER
STATES WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS THERE'S
AND IT'S AN AGREEMENT AMONG
MEMBER STATES SO THEY'VE
ALREADY AGREED TO THESE
BASELINE REQUIREMENTS SO ONCE
OF US MILITARY'S OR ANYONE AND
THAT'S THE OTHER GOOD THING IS
THAT IT'S NOT JUST FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES SO IT DOESN'T. CREATE
KIND OF THAT SPECIAL CLASS THAT
THAT PERCEPTION THAT PEOPLE
MIGHT BE AFRAID OF AND THEY
STREAMLINED STREAMLINED
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS STATES
ALLOWING PROFESSIONALS TO BEGIN
WORKING RIGHT AWAY FROM THEIR
HOMES REGISTERED WITH THEIR
HOME STATE WHILE PROVIDING
PUBLIC PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE
PROCESS FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THEY A LOT OF THEM HAVE THAT
KIND OF ALREADY HAVE A PORTAL.
FOR TRACKING THEIR THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE REGISTERED UNDER THE
CONTACT SO COMPACTS ARE THE
ONLY REAL TRUE RECIPROCITY THE
EXISTING MEMBER STATES BECAUSE
IT IS TRULY AN AGREEMENT AMONG
THE MEMBERS AND JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT HERE JUST THOSE
NUMBERS THERE'S A TWENTY FIVE
STATES HAVE APPROVED THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY LICENSE OR
COMPACT THIRTY THREE NURSE
LICENSURE. COMPACT EMT COMPACT
EIGHTEEN STATES HAVE APPROVED A
AND THE PSYCHOLOGY COMPACT TEN
HAVE APPROVED SO FAR AND
THERE'S OPEN LEGISLATION AND
ALL OF THOSE CONTACTS AND ALSO
A NEW COMPACT IS HAS BEEN
STARTED FOR TWO TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH IS SPEECH AND LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGY. AND I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT FORTY STATES
HAVE PASSED OVER AT COMPAQ'S IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS AND
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF NINE WITH
NINE APPROVED. SO WE HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH THAT HERE. SENATE
GLAZER THANK YOU CHAIR ALLEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
IT'S ENLIGHTENING AND
APPRECIATED AND I DON'T WANT MY
QUESTION TO BE MISUNDERSTOOD
BECAUSE THE DELAY FOR ONE
PERSON THAT DID NOT FOR ONE IS
TOO MANY. KLAY FOR OUR MILITARY
SPOUSES BUT- I HAVE NOT HEARD
ANY ANY FACTS ABOUT THE EXTENT
OF THE PROBLEM. OKAY I KNOW
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM SPOUSES
IN A FEW MINUTES AND I'M SURE
THEY'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT GIVE
US SOME REAL LIFE EXAMPLES
WHICH IS HELPFUL. BUT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE YOU HAVE
FACTS ON HOW BIG OF A PROBLEM
THAT IS IN CALIFORNIA. SO IT
IT'S KIND OF HARD RIGHT NOW
BASED ON AND I'M JUST NOT. IN
THE PAST NOT REALLY HAVING A
MECHANISM FOR TRACKING THESE
THINGS I THINK LIKE ISN'T. AS
APRIL WAS SAYING THERE'S- NOW
THERE'S KIND OF. THERE'S A WAY
TO KIND OF COMMUNICATE WITH THE
BOARD AND FIND OUT WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING. BUT THE ONLY THING WE
REALLY. THE ONLY INFORMATION I
HAD AS FAR AS DATA WAS ON THE
DC A- REPORT THAT WAS PUT OUT
IN APRIL. THAT JUST STATED.
KIND OF THAT SATISFACTION LEVEL
OR THE RESPONSE LEVEL THAT THEY
WERE GETTING FROM BOARDS BUT IT
WASN'T REALLY PARTICULAR TO HOW
LONG IT TOOK. OKAY AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
YOU TALKED ABOUT WAYS IN WHICH
YOU TRY TO FACILITATE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT APPRECIATE IT AND
I KNOW. YOU'RE NOT SATISFIED IN
WE'RE ALL NOT SATISFIED AND WE
CAN DO MORE. BUT YOU HAVE ANY
FACTS ABOUT HOW MANY AND
MILITARY SPOUSES BEEN TURNED
DOWN. OR ANYTHING ANY FACTS
ABOUT THE DELAYS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED. NO I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION HANDY BUT I'D BE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO YOUR
OFFICE I WOULD CERTAINLY BE
HELPFUL AND TO. THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM DEAD.
TEACHER CREDENTIALING DO YOU
HAVE ANY FACTS ON HOW MANY.
MILITARY SPELLS HAVE BEEN
TURNED DOWN OR THE DELAYS AND
THE PROCESSING OF THEIR
LICENSURE. AT NO NOT
SPECIFICALLY THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TRACKING AT BEST OKAY IN THE
STATE BAR SAME QUESTION AS I
MENTIONED WE WILL RECEIVE THREE
APPLICATIONS TO HAVE BEEN
ADMITTED AND ONE IS PENDING. SO
I CAN IMAGINE THAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED MANY DELAYS OKAY
WELL MY QUESTION OBVIOUSLY
ELIMINATES A CHALLENGE FOR US
WE WANT TO DO BETTER WE NOW
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE DO MORE.
BY WE DO NEED SOME FACTUAL
BASIS TO UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT
OF THE PROBLEM AND- AND- TO
SOME LIMITED EXTENT THE STATE
BAR HAS SOME INFORMATION BUT I
THINK IT. POINTS OUT A BLIND
SPOT WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT AND I MEAN I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR MORE TESTIMONY IN
A FEW MINUTES AND- AND THAT
WILL GET ELIMINATED SOME EXTENT
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
BODY OF FACTS. THANK YOU MISTER
HERE. SENATE ROTH THANK YOU AND
I SPECIFICALLY WANT TO THANK
THE STATE BAR FOR STEPPING OUT
ON THIS. IN OF MEN MS NINE
YEARS REMEMBERS OUR NOSE BUT
THIS WAS AN ISSUE THAT WAS.
FIRST BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
ISSUE BUT ATTORNEYS IN PRACTICE.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON AT
THE STATE BAR'S BEEN WORKING ON
IT AND FINALLY SOMETHING IS
COME TO FRUITION NAY I FOR ONE
APPRECIATE IT. I CAN ADDRESS MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENT WITH RESPECT
TO. THE LAWYERS BUT BEING FIRST
LICENSED IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA AND THEN COMING TO
CALIFORNIA TO WORK FOR OF. A
NON MILITARY GOVERNMENT AGENCY
EVENTUALLY AS A NON CALIFORNIA
LAWYER AND TAKING THE
CALIFORNIA BAR AND- FORTUNATELY
THEY MADE A MISTAKE IN THE
ADMITTED ME. BUT THE PROBLEM IS
THE BAR RELEASED ELICITS
CHANGES GIVEN TWICE A YEAR. SO
IF YOUR MILITARY SPOUSE YOU
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA BY THE TIME
YOU FIGURE OUT YOU KNOW WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT YOU FIGURE
OUT WHERE THE- COURSES IN WORDS
GIVEN TO STUDY FOR THE BAR YOU
GO THROUGH THE- MONTHS LONG
PROCESS OF STUDYING FOR THE BAR
YOU FINALLY TAKE THE BAR EXAM
YOU THEN WAIT MONTHS FOR THE
BAR EXAM TO BE SCORED. AND YOU
GET YOUR RESULT. YOUR RELATED
THE GAME THE YOU THEN LOOK
START LOOKING FOR A JOB. YOU
WILL TO MILLY FIND A JOB AND
YOUR MILITARY MEMBER SPOUSE
GETS ORDERS AND IS REASSIGNED
EITHER BEFORE YOU TAKE YOUR JOB
OR WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF
SECURING IT THAT'S A- A
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE PROCESS AND
WHILE THAT IS NOT THE SAME I
ASSUME QUITE THE SAME PROCESSES
WITH TEACHER CREDENTIALING. OR
WITH THE OCCUPATIONS AND
PROFESSIONS OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DEALS WITH IT IS CERTAINLY A
PROBLEM. THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS I'M AS I UNDERSTAND THE
RULE YOU CAN PRACTICE FOR FIVE
YEARS AS A REGISTERED MILITARY
SPOUSE. AND I THINK THAT'S
EXCELLENT THAT THAT SORT OF
BRIDGES THAT PERIOD OF TIME
WHEN A MILITARY FAMILY IS GOING
TO. GET HERE THEN WERE CUTER
AND SEE YOUR ORDERS AND THEN
MOVE ON AND AT SOME POINT YOU
DECIDE WHETHER YOU WANT TO STAY
HERE. AND THEN YOU CAN TAKE THE
CALIFORNIA BAR FOR AN ATTORNEY.
AND GO INTO PRACTICE I WOULD
LIKE TO DRILL DOWN A LITTLE BIT
ON THE ON TWO THINGS ONE THE
SUPERVISION ISSUE AND ONE. TIME
IN PRACTICE IF THAT'S STILL AN
ISSUE FIRST THE SUPERVISION IF
I HAVE THE CURRENT COPY OF THE-
THE RULE OR THE REGULATION THE
DUTIES OF THE EMPLOYER. APPEAR
TO INVOLVE COMPLETING AN
APPLICATION AND SIGNING A
DECLARATION. AND THEN GENERALLY
OVERSEEING THE WORK OF THE
LAWYER DOESN'T SEEM TO BE. TWO
DIFFERENT THAN THE FUNCTION I
PERFORMED IN MY PURSE ONE OF MY
PRAYER LIVES WHEN I MANAGE A
LAW FIRM. OF PARTNERS AND
ASSOCIATES WE HAVE SOME
MENTORSHIP AND SUPERVISORY.
RESPONSIBILITY IS THERE
ANYTHING BEYOND WHAT I JUST
READ IN THIS RULE. NO THERE'S
NOTHING BEYOND THE ROLE SO IS A
REGISTERED TO A- MILITARY
SPOUSE ATTORNEY ENTITLED TO
SIGN A PLEADING. IT WITH SIGN
OFF FROM THE SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY THEY CAN BUT YOUR BUT
THIS BILL TO MILITARY SPOUSES
SIGNATURE WOULD BE ON THE
BOTTOM OF THE PLEADING. WITH
SOME CALIFORNIA BAR NUMBER
ATTACHED TO IT. OKAY WELL THEN.
LET ME ASK THIS QUESTION HAVING
TO DO WITH TIME AND PRACTICE SO
I ASSUME. IF THAT'S STILL AN
ISSUE TIME AND PRACTICES
RELEVANT TERMS OF WILL WHICH
BAR EXAM YOU TAKE PERHAPS IS
THAT STILL DO YOU STILL IF YOU
PRACTICE MORE THAN FIVE OR SIX
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA DO YOU
STILL GET TO TAKE AN ATTORNEY'S
BAR EXAM. I'M SO SORRY CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT ONE MORE TIME. THE
TIME IN PRACTICE ISSUE HAS TO
DO WITH. YOUR TIME THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SPENT PRACTICINGAND
WHAT YOU QUALIFIED TO TAKE IF
YOU'RE TAKING A BURKE SAM. I
ASSUME. AND THIS CALIFORNIA'S
STILL OFFER A OF A SEPARATE
BURKE SAM FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN IN. PRACTICE A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF YEARS. YES SO BUT THE
TIME PRACTICE REFERS TO THE
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY'S TIME AND
PRACTICE. OKAY WELL MAYBE YOU
COULD WELL THIS IS THE OKAY
MAYBE YOU CAN EXPLAIN THAT IN
THE NOTES THAT SOMEONE GAVE ME
A MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY DOES
NOT ACCRUE TIME AND PRACTICE
UNDER RULE NINE POINT FORTY ONE
POINT ONE. BUT YOU SAY THE A
TIME IN PRACTICE REQUIREMENTS
RELATES TO THE SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY'S. LET ME GET TO THAT
PORTION OF THE RULE. AND I MAY
NOT HAVE THE COMPLETE RULE. I'M
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE OBJECTIONS ARE I'M SURE OUT
HERE FROM THE MILITARY SPOUSE
ATTORNEYS I THINK THE NEXT
PANEL IS GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THIS TOO SO THE SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY NEEDS TO HAVE AT LEAST
FOUR YEARS OF PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA OKAY SO IF I'M A
REGISTERED MILITARY SPOUSES TWO
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. IF I'M A
MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY AND I
PRACTICE HERE. FOR FIVE YEARS
WHICH IS THE MAXIMUM UNDER THE
RULE. AND I'VE HAD THREE YEARS
OF PRACTICE IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA. FOR A TOTAL OF EIGHT
YEARS WHICH BAR EXAM BUT I
TAKING CALIFORNIA THE ATTORNEYS
BURKE SAM OR THE BAR EXAM THE
SAME BAR EXAM BUT SOMEBODY
POPPING OUT OF LAW SCHOOL WOULD
TAKE WELL I HAVE ONE CAT SO IF
YOU ARE COMING FROM ANOTHER
JURISDICTION UNDER THE
REGISTERED MILITARY SPOUSE
ATTORNEY YOU HAVE TO HAVE
PRACTICED IN YOUR HOME
JURISDICTION OR ANOTHER
JURISDICTION FOR FOUR YEARS AGO
BUT SO I HAVE NINE YEARS YOU
HAVE NINE YEARS SO IF I HAVE
NINE YEARS WHAT I TAKE WHICH
BAR EXAM WHEN I TAKE IN
CALIFORNIA. ATTORNEYS ATTORNEYS
EXAM PERFECT THANK YOU TWENTY
EXAM THANK YOU THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR TAKING THIS ON THANK YOU
MISTER OSCAR. OKAY AB TARANTULA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK THIS IS A BIGGER PICTURE
THAT THE ADD ROLE AND I ARE
VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN BACK AT
ROLE BECAUSE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL AND THAT IS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN UNIFORM. TO KEEP THEM
IN THE MILITARY AS LONG AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN SO THIS OUT REACH
PROGRAM TO KEEP THE SPOUSES
INVOLVED ALSO KIND OF WORK
TOGETHER. THE OTHER THING WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE AS AN
EXAMPLE IN THE MARINE CORPS
HERE AND CAMP PENDLETON WE
RELEASE ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
MARINES A YEAR AND- THEY GO OFF.
AND THEY DON'T STATE CALIFORNIA
SO THAT EXPERTISE WHATEVER IT
IS WE LOSEIT. IF WE CAN USE
THAT ARM TO KEEP THE WIVES
EMPLOYED BECOME PROFESSIONALS
IN WHATEVER CAPACITY THEY CAN
MORE THAN LIKELY WILL KEEP THE-
VOTERS MARINES SAILORS WITH US.
SO I SEE IT'S WORKING HAND IN
HAND AND OF COURSE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF YOU CAN MINE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HERE IN
THE STATE. SO I CONGRATULATE
YOU OFFER WHAT YOU'RE DOING BUT
WE'RE WORKING ON IT JUST LET
YOU KNOW ADMIRAL THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU DO WERE. ON THE
COMMITTEE THE COUNCIL THAT I
WOULD JUST APPOINTED TO WAS
TALKING JUST ABOUT THIS AND HOW
WE CAN HELP THE SPOUSES HOW WE
CAN HELP. THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM HOW WE COULD MAKE SURE
THAT OUR MILITARY. THIS IS OUR
OUR OUR ENVIRONMENTALLY SAFE
AND FREE AND JUST EVERYONE
WORKING TOGETHER SO RIGHT NOW
THE SPIRIT IN CALIFORNIA IS TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH EVERYONE AND
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT TIME
FOR YOU TO APPEAR. BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE EMPHASIZED TO UP HOW
MUCH WE CAN PARTNER WITH YOU IS
A STATE. AND HOW MUCH. THE
VALUE YOU BRING. TO OUR OUR OUR
DISPELLED BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MANY WOMEN RIGHT NOW SERVING.
SO WHEN USE YOUR SPOUSE I JUST
DON'T THINK OF WOMEN I THINK OF
MEN AS WELL. BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE WOMEN ARE ARE ARE SHIPPING
AND THEY REACH HIGH RANKS IS
THAT RIGHT TO ADMIRAL. YES THEY
DO. SO I CONGRATULATE YOU BEING
HERE AND SO I HOPE TO SUPPORT
YOU AS CHAIR OF. MILITARY
COMMITTEE AND NOW ON THE ON THE
COUNSEL FOR THE GOVERNOR. SO IF
THERE IS ANYTHING IN SPECIFIC
THAT YOU'D LIKE TO. BRING TO US
TODAY THAT WE CAN HELP YOU WITH
PLEASE DON'T LEAVE THE ROOM
WITHOUT GIVING IT TO US.
SPECIFICALLY THAT IS ON THE
HORIZON THAT YOU NEED IS TAKE A
LOOK AT. IS THERE ANYTHING
THERE IF YOU'RE THINKING OF OUR
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE PERHAPS
GO BACK TELL US LIFE. WELL LET
ME JUST SAY THIS IS KIND OF
PIGGY BACKING TO ON ON ON
SENATOR GLAZERS POINT THE LAST
KIND OF REQUEST ADDING FOR US
AS WE WENT AT IT TOO YOU KNOW
WE NEED THAT INFORMATION SO I
THINK YOU KNOW LOOKING AT IS
THERE A WAY FOR ALL LICENSING
BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA. OR
ENTITIES TO. BY SOME SORT
ANNUAL KIND OF REPORT ON THIS
IN WHICH IT WHICH WOULD BE A
AYE AND IMPLEMENTATION BUT ALSO
ON YOU KNOW. HOW MANY SOURCES
OF COME TO YOU HOW MANY ACTIVE
DUTY HAVE COME TO YOU HOW MANY.
DISCIPLINARY EVEN REPORTS DO
YOU HAVE JUST SO WE HAVE THAT
DATA BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE IT
EITHER. AND I THINK A REPORT.
THAT MAYBE I'D. I COORDINATED
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S MILITARY
COUNCIL MIGHT BE GOOD. GENERAL
WELL LET ME JUST SAY THIS SERVE
AS TO THAT GENERAL POINT YOU
KNOW. I THINK OUR STATE AID
BOARDS AND AGENCIES NEED TO
LOOK INTERNALLY WE KNOW THAT
MILITARY FAMILIES MOVE
TYPICALLY EVERY TWO TO THREE
YEARS SOMETIMES LONGER
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
PARTICULAR SERVICE BRANCHES AND
WHAT THE. THE OCCUPATIONAL CODE
IS AND OTHER SITUATIONS BUT IF
YOU'RE GONNA MOVE EVERY TWO OR
THREE YEARS AND YOU NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR INTERNAL
PROCESS SEES. AND IS SOMEONE
WHO MOVES EVERY TWO OR THREE
YEARS AND THEN MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA AND THEY GET THE
FAMILY GET THE HOUSE HOLD GOODS
IN THE HOUSE FIRST OF ALL TO
GET A HOUSE. OR AN APARTMENT
THEY GET THE STUFF IN THE HOUSE
OF THE APARTMENT. THEY GET THE
KIDS IN THE SCHOOL. THEY THEN
FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY'RE
LIVING. AND NOW THEY'RE GOING
TO TURN AROUND AND TAKE THE
OCCUPATION THE LICENSE THE
FIELD WHATEVER THERE IS THEIR
CAREER AND TRY TO GO TO WORK.
HOW LONG IS IT GOING TO TAKE
FROM THE TIME THEY HIT
CALIFORNIA TO THE TIME THEY GET
THROUGH YOUR PROCESS IN ORDER
TO GET. APPLY FOR BE
INTERVIEWED BY AND SELECTED FOR
A JOB IF IT'S. IF IT'S EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO TWO YEARS. TOTAL TIME
THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR THESE
MILITARY FAMILIES AND SO AS
WITH THE BAR EXAM WAITING FOR
THE BAR TEST AND THE SCORES AND
THE ALL THE REST THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THAT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HARRIS
COMPRESS THAT TIME HOWEVER WE
DO IT SO THAT SOMEBODY CAN GET
HERE GET THE HOUSE THE
APARTMENT GET THE KIDS IN
SCHOOL GET THROUGH YOUR PROCESS
AND THEN HAVE SOME USEABLE
PERIOD OF TIME. IN ORDER TO
WORK OTHERWISE IT'S NOT WORTH
THE EFFORT EVEN IF THE DOD.
GIVES US FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS FOR
A. CUNNINGHAM FREE DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE AND I THINK THAT
GOES TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE IS
TALKING ABOUT HERE WHETHER WE
HAVE ANY STATISTICS TO BACK IT
UP OR NOT. WE KNOW HOW LONG. WE
FOR WE KNOW WHAT OUR STATISTICS
ARE PROCESSING STATISTICS ARE
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK WE NEED
TO LOOK AT. YOU KNOW AS A
STATED INTERNALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU WELL
THIS IS GREAT REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT I KNOW THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF FAITH OR
THEIR- COMMUNICATION. BOTH WITH
WITH ALL THE COMMITTEES THAT
ARE REPRESENTED HERE TODAY AND
I'M EACH AND EVERYONE OF THESE
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND-
THANKS FOR COMMITTED TO OUR
MILITARY FAMILIES. OKAY SO
WHAT'S NEXT PLUS TAX ACTUALLY
HEAR FROM SOME MILITARY SPOUSES.
NOW IS WITH JAMISON IS
COFOUNDER MISSION LICENSE SO
SONYA TRAFFIC WHO'S A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER IN ALEXANDER
JOHNSON WHO'S ACT ACTUALLY CO
FOUNDER THE MILITARY SPOUSE
PROFESSIONAL NETWORK AT TRAVIS
AIR FORCE BASE HERE IN IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK WE'RE
GONNA START WITH YOU MISS
JAMIESON. THE SUN OKAY.
CHALLENGER GLAZER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
TRIANGLE QUICK BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE INSURED ON TIME HERE. MY
NAME IS WOULD BE JAMESON AND I
AM A PROUD NAVY SPOUSE AN
ATTORNEY AND THE CO FOUNDER OF
MISSION LCENSE WHICH IS A
MILITARY SUPPOSED ON BUSINESS
HELPING PROFESSIONALS NAVIGATE
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BARRIERS.
I'M ALSO THE PAST PRESIDENT OF
THE MILITARY SPOUSE TREATY
NETWORK WHICH WAS REFERENCED BY
THE BAR HEY AND I THINK WAS
ALSO REFERENCE OUR EFFORTS
STARTING BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. TO ENACT A AN ATTORNEY
ON LICENSING ROLE IN THE STATE.
OF MY HUSBAND'S A NAVY
HELICOPTER PILOT SERVING AT
NAVAL STATION NORTH ISLAND IN
CORONADO. AND IT'S MY GREAT
HONOR TO SUPPORT HIS SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY AND I COULD NOT BE
MORE PROUD OF HIS TWENTY THREE
YEARS OVER TWENTY THREE YEARS
OF SERVICE. HOWEVER THAT
COMMITMENT COMES AT A COSTS NOT
ONLY TO OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
PROTEST BUT TO THEIR FAMILIES
AS WELL. I'D LIKE TO START BY
DRAWING YOUR ATTENTION TO AN
NBC NEWS STORY FROM JULY
TWELFTH ENTITLED WIRE MANY OF
MILITARY WHY ARE MANY OF
AMERICA'S MILITARY FAMILIES
GOING HUNGRY. THE STORY
HIGHLIGHTED THE STRUGGLE OF A
SAN DIEGO FAMILY AND THOUSANDS
OF OTHER MILITARY FAMILIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO
ROUTINELY RELY ON ASSISTANCE TO
MAKE ENDS MEET.DUE TO THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING IN SAN IN CITIES
LIKE SAN DIEGO AND THE
TRANSIENT MILITARY LIFESTYLE
THAT MAKES IT CHALLENGING FOR
SPOUSES TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF THEIR
FAMILIES. WE'RE HERE TODAY
DISCUSSING THAT LAST ISSUE
CHALLENGES TO MILITARY SPOUSES
MAINTAINING MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS. IN TANGENTIALLY BUT AS OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE ESTIMATED
THAT THE SPOUSE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IS AS HIGH AS TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT. MILITARY SPOUSES FIND
THEMSELVES IN A CONSTANT
RECESSION THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
WOMEN. SINCE 92% OF A DUTY
SPOUSES ARE FEMALE THESE FEMALE
SPOUSES EARN ON AVERAGE 25%
LESS THAN THEIR CIVILIAN
COUNTERPARTS. THESE NUMBERS ARE
THE RESULT OF MANY OF A
MULTIPLE SYSTEMIC BARRIERS
INCLUDING EMPLOYERS LACKING IN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE MILITARY
LIFESTYLE THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE AND OVERLY
BURDENSOME OCCUPATIONAL
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS. MY
STORY HIGHLIGHTS THE CHALLENGES
WITH LICENSING I WENT TO LAW
SCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA BAR AND EVENTUALLY
STARTED MY OWN FIRM IN SAN
DIEGO. THEN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE MY HUSBAND EMAILED ME
FROM AFGHANISTAN TO SAY THAT
THE NAVY WAS RELOCATING HIM TO
FLORIDA UPON HIS RETURN. HE
WOULD BE ISSUED ORDERS FOR A
PERMANENT CHANGE OF STATION
WHICH I FIND TO BE A VERY
IRONIC TERM BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING PERMANENT ABOUT BEING
IN THE MILITARY. A MILITARY
FAMILIES MOVE ON AVERAGE EVERY
TWO OR THREE YEARS I
IMMEDIATELY RESEARCH AND
DISCOVERED THAT IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE WORKING IN FLORIDA AS
AN ATTORNEY I WOULD HAVE TO SIT
FOR YET ANOTHER BAR EXAM. I
WOULD HAVE BEEN MY THIRD AFTER
CALIFORNIA AND WASHINGTON STATE
ON THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE
EXAMINATION A PREP COURSE ALL
OF THE PREPARATION THAT GOES
INTO THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. ALSO
WING INTO MY DECISION MAKING
WAS WOULD I BE ABLE TO BUILD A
NEW CLIENT BASE SIR YOU TALKED
ABOUT THAT YOU KNOW WITH THOSE
LIMITED WINDOW OF TIME THAT WE
HAVE WOULD I BE ABLE TO BUILD A
NEW CLIENT BASE. OR WOULD I BE
ABLE TO FIND SOMEONE TO HIRE ME
UP IN A PLACE WHERE I HAD NO
PROFESSIONAL NETWORK. COMMITTEE
I DECIDED NOT TO SIT FOR THIRD
EXAM. AS THE TIMING AND IT.
DIDN'T MAKE SENSE FOR US. WE
MOVED THREE MORE TIMES. BEFORE
RETURNING TO SAN DIEGO LAST
YEAR SO WE MOVED FOUR TIMES IN
SIX YEARS. IT WAS QUITE SIMPLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO KEEP UP WITH THE
CYCLE OF MOVING. TAKING A BAR
EXAMINATION AND FINDING A NEW A
NEW JOB IN EACH NEW LOCATION. I
QUESTIONED WHETHER IT COULD
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT MY HUSBAND
SERVICE WITHOUT LOSING MY OWN
CAREER AND A PIECE OF MYSELF.
FORTUNATELY I DISCOVERED THE
MILITARY SPOUSE TREATING
NETWORK. OF OUR ASSOCIATION FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES AND CONNECTED
WITH OVER TWELVE HUNDRED OTHER
ATTORNEYS STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN THEIR CAREERS. WE
BANDED TOGETHER TO ADVOCATE FOR
CHANGES TO LICENSING RULES. AND
I'M PROUD TO REPORT THE NUMBERS
ACTUALLY THIRTY EIGHT SO THIS
WAS US IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED. AND I'M
HAPPY TO SAY THIS IS WHAT THE
MAP LOOKS LIKE TODAY SO THERE
ARE NOW THIRTY EIGHT
JURISDICTIONS. THAT HAVE SOME
SORT OF LICENSING ACCOMMODATION
FOR A MILITARY SPOUSE ATTORNEY.
AS OF MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT INCLUDES CALIFORNIA WHICH
I WILL RETURN TO IN A MOMENT.
NOW I RECOGNIZE THAT ATTORNEYS
ARE NOT GENERALLY A SYMPATHETIC
GROUP. BUT I DISCOVERED THAT
THIS ISSUE IS MUCH GREATER THAN
MY OWN EXPERIENCE. AS I THINK
IT WAS REFERENCED ON THE
PREVIOUS PANEL ALMOST 34% OF
MILITARY SPOUSES REQUIRE A
LICENSE TO WORK ACROSS THE
PROFESSIONS. WHEN DONE RIGHT
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING BENEFITS
BOTH WORKERS AND CONSUMERS.
HOWEVER MY EXPERIENCE IS THE
CURRENT LICENSING RULES ARE.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
PROTECTIONIST AND NOT BASED ON
ACTUAL COMPETENCY TO PERFORM
THE DUTIES OF THE ONE OF THE
WORK. ON THE CONFUSING
PATCHWORK OF RULES ALONG WITH
THE TIME AND COST OF OBTAINING
A LICENSE WITH EACH MOVE OFTEN
RESULTS IN A MILITARY SPOUSE
SETTLING FOR UNLICENSED
EMPLOYMENT OUTSIDE OF THEIR
EDUCATION AND SKILLS SIDE OR
OPTING OUT OF THE WORK FORCE
ENTIRELY. THIS CREATES
FINANCIAL AND EMOTIONAL STRESS
AND INFLUENCES A FAMILY'S
DECISION A IN THE MILITARY
FACTORS THAT HER OUR MILITARY'S
READINESS RETENTION AND
RECRUITING. A SPOUSE'S ABILITY
TO BUILD A MEANINGFUL CAREER IS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT FACTOR IN THE
VETERANS ABILITY CHAIRED
TRANSITION FROM ACTIVE DUTY TO
CIVILIAN LIFE THIS IS WHY WE
FOUNDED MISSION LICENSE AND WE
HELP MILITARY SPOUSES NAVIGATE
THESE ISSUES. OF THE TWO TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN LICENSE TO
WORK STUDY WHICH I INCLUDED A
LINK TO FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR
JUSTICE FOUND THAT CALIFORNIA
LICENSES SIXTY TWO LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME. OCCUPATIONS
THE THIRD MOST IN THE COUNTRY
ARIZONA AND CALIFORNIA WERE
NAMED AS THE MOST WIDELY AN
OWNER SLEE LICENSE STATES
EARLIER THIS YEAR I DON'T KNOW
FOLKS ARE AWARE BUT- TO BE BOLD
ACTION. THE FIRST STATE TO
IMPLEMENT UNIVERSAL
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSING ERRORS
ON HIS LICENSING BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
RECOGNIZE OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES
GRANTED IN OTHER STATES. SO
WITH ALL OF THAT MIND UP FOR
THREE COMMENDED TENS OUR STATE
IS THE COMMITTEE FOR ECONOMIC
AND- BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE SECTION SIXTY SIX.
REGULATE THE ADMISSION RETURN
TO PRACTICE LAW IN CALIFORNIA
AS DISCUSSED CALIFORNIA
APPROVED RULE NINE POINT FOUR
ONE POINT ONE EARLIER THIS YEAR.
AND WELL WE ARE ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT THAT PROGRESS THE NEW
RULE IS INCREDIBLY PROBLEMATIC
THE BURDENSOME SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENT UNNECESSARILY
STIGMATIZES MILITARY SPOUSES BY
TREATING THEM AS NO MORE THAN
INTERNS REGARDLESS OF THE YEARS
IN PRACTICE. A MILITARY SPOUSE
pWITH NO TIES TO THE TO THE AREA
MUST FIND AN EMPLOYER WILLING
TO SIGN A DECLARATION
COMMITTING TO ASSUME
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEM THE EMPLOYER MUST APPROVE
EACH AND EVERY QUARTER OR
DEPOSITION APPEARANCE IN
WRITING. AND READ AND APPROVE
ALL PLEADINGS AND IN FACT ANY
DOCUMENTS SUBMITTED TO A THIRD
PARTY WHICH I READ TO INCLUDE
EVEN AN EMAIL. TO A THIRD PARTY
HAS TO BE APPROVED BY THAT
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY. IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER ANOTHER STATE
SERVER SENATOR ROSS TO YOUR
POINT ON THE TIME IN PRACTICE
ISSUES I THINK THE QUESTION IS.
WILL THE TIME SPENT PRACTICING
UNDER THIS REGISTERED MILITARY
SPOUSE RULE IN CALIFORNIA ALLOW
A SPOUSE TO THAN WE'VE INTO
ANOTHER STATE LIKE TEXAS THAT
REQUIRES FIVE OUT OF SEVEN. OR
WHATEVER THEIR YEAR IN PRACTICE
TIME IN PRACTICE REQUIREMENTS
ARE. IT BASED ON THE
RESTRICTIONS OF THIS RULE THE
OTHER PROBLEM IS ALSO LOGISTICS
THE RULE STIGMATIZES SPOUSES BY
FORCING THEM TO JOB HUNT
WITHOUT THE LICENSE IN HAND TO
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT GET THE
LICENSE UNTIL THEY FIND. THE
ATTORNEY TO SUPERVISE THEM
MEANING A MILITARY SPOUSE IS
LIKELY TO BE PASSED OVER BY
EMPLOYERS FOR SOMEBODY WHO
ALREADY HAS A LICENSE IN HAND.
THESE CONCERNS WERE CONVEYED TO
THE STATE BAR DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD LAST YEAR
DESPITE RECEIVING THIRTY SEVEN
COMMONS OPPOSING THE RULE OR
PROPOSING AN ALTERNATIVE SUCH
AS MENTORSHIP. I'M AN ONLY
EIGHT COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF THE
RULE NO SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
WERE MADE PRIOR TO ITS
ADOPTION. I HEARD THE NUMBERS
EARLIER IT SOUNDS LIKE THREE
SPOUSES HAVE APPLIED AND WE
RECOGNIZE I THINK IT'S ONLY
BEEN IN EFFECT SINCE MARCH
FIRST BUT- THERE ARE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY. MILITARY SPOUSE
JEANETTE WHAT NETWORK MEMBERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU KNOW
ANECDOTAL ANECDOTALLY HEARING
FROM OUR MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT
SOME EVEN WITH EMPLOYERS WHO
ALREADY HAVE THEM WORKING AS A
CLERK ROLE HAVE SAID. WE ARE
NOT WILLING TO TAKE ON THE
BURDENS OF THIS RULE YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO SIT FOR THE
BAR EXAM AND OTHERS ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE TIME IN
PRACTICE IN BEING ABLE TO WEAVE
INTO THE NEXT STATE. SO THEY
ARE OPTING. TO SIT FOR THE BAR
EXAM RATHER THAN UTILIZING THIS
ROLE. PRESIDENT WE BELIEVE THAT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS NECESSARY
TO OBTAIN A MORE PRACTICAL RULE.
AS REFERENCED EARLIER MSG AND
HAS IT ADOPTED OR HAS DEVELOPED
A MODEL RULE FOR THE ADMISSION
OF MILITARY SPOUSES THAT
PROVIDES THE PUBLIC SAFETY
PROTECTIONS WITHOUT
UNNECESSARILY STIGMATIZING
MILITARY SPOUSES SEEKING TO
PRACTICE THE LAW. ON SOME OF
THE THIRTY EIGHT JURISDICTIONS
AND I WANTED TO CARESS I THINK
THE NUMBER REFERENCE WAS THERE
WERE ELEVEN JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE SOME KIND OF SUPERVISION
REQUIREMENT I BELIEVE IT'S NINE
AND TWO OF THOSE ARE BASED ON.
TIME AND PRACTICE SO YOU'RE
ONLY SUPERVISED IF YOU'RE UNDER
FIVE YEARS OR UNDER TWO YEARS
IN PRACTICE WHERE IS CALIFORNIA
REGARDLESS OF TIME. A YEARS
YOU'RE REQUIRED TO BE
SUPERVISED SO THE LAST TWO
SUGGESTIONS ALL MAKE WHICH I
THINK HAVE ALREADY BEEN BEEN
COVERED IN PART ARE CONTINUING
TO BUILD UPON THE FOUNDATIONS
THAT ALREADY. EXISTS AND
ADOPTING THE TWO THOUSAND SO
OUTSIDE OF ATTORNEY LICENSING
NOW I'M TALKING GENERAL
MILITARY SPOUSE LICENSING. IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS ADOPTING
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN UNIVERSITY
OF MINNESOTA MILITARY SPOUSE
LICENSOR LICENSURE STUDY. TO
STAY THE OCCUPATIONAL BOARD
SHALL ALLOW LICENSURE. AND SO
REMOVING UNCERTAINTY AND
ADOPTING A COMPREHENSIVE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND THEN
FINALLY AS WAS BROUGHT UP IN
THE LAST PANEL ON. REQUIRING
REPORTING THINK OF SKIPS A LOT
OF THIS BUT- I WAS RECOMMENDED
RECOMMENDED BY THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN UNIVERSITY OF
MINNESOTA STUDY TRAINING AND
REPORTING SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
REQUIRING REPORTING ON THE
NUMBER OF MILITARY SPOUSES
BEING PROCESSED THROUGH THE
SYSTEM PROVIDES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY. I'LL CONCLUDE
BY SAYING THAT THE ONLY
CERTAINTY OF MILITARY LIFE IS
UNCERTAINTY. A MILITARY SPOUSES
DO NOT DECIDE WHERE WE LIVE OR
FOR HOW LONG OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS CANNOT TURN DOWN A
TRANSFER OR QUIT THEIR JOBS IF
THE MOVE ISN'T IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THEIR FAMILIES. AS
MILITARY SPOUSES WE TAKE GREAT
PRIDE IN THEIR SERVICE AND IN
OUR ROLES AS MILITARY SPOUSES
WE DON'T SPEAK SPECIALIST THE
SPECIAL TREATMENT BUT WE DO ASK
FOR COMMONSENSE RULES TO BE PUT
IN PLACE TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD. EVERY BARRIER REDUCE
CONTRIBUTES TO OUR NATIONAL
DEFENSE BY MAKING LIFE A LITTLE
EASIER FOR MILITARY FAMILIES
INCLUDING THOSE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN NEED OF A SECOND
INCOME TO MAKE ENDS MEET. I ASK
THAT YOU GIVE THESE. THREE
CHANGES YOUR SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO HELP MILITARY
SPOUSES BUILDING MEANINGFUL
CAREERS AND SUPPORT THE
RETENTION OF FAMILIES IN THE
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CRITICS REMAIN
HERE FROM MISTRUST LOOK WHO'S.
TO THE RESPECT OF A SOCIAL
WORKER CAUCUSES WERE. SENATOR
ALLEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERIENCE THAT
IS INSURED BY MANY OTHER
MILITARY DEPENDENTS WITH
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES MY NAME
IS SONYA TRAFFIC AND I'M A
PROUD AIR FORCE SPOUSE. OF A
HUSBAND WHO IS CURRENTLY
DEPLOYED OVERSEAS. IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WHEN MY
HUSBAND FIRST JOINED THE
AIRFORCE I HAD COMPLETED MY
GRADUATE STUDIES IN SOCIAL WORK
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND LOS ANGELES.
AFTER OBTAINING MY MASTER'S
DEGREE MY HUSBAND WAS STATIONED
AT LACKLAND AIR FORCE BASE
TEXAS AND STAYED FOR SEVERAL
YEARS. FORTUNATELY FOR ME I WAS
THERE LONG ENOUGH TO OBTAIN
BOTH MY LICENSE AS A MASTER
LEVEL SOCIAL WORKER AND THE
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORK LICENSE.
TO DO SO I COMPLETED THE
REQUIRED THREE THOUSAND
SUPERVISION HOURS ALONG WITH
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS TO
INCLUDE THE ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS BOARDS
EXAMINATION. I PRACTICE IN SAN
ANTONIO AS AN ELEMENT STILL
VERY ELEMENTS W. FOR FOUR YEARS
BEFORE OBTAINING MY CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORK LICENSE IN JUNE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THAT SAME
MONTH WE RECEIVED ORDERS TO
BEALE AIR FORCE BASE CALIFORNIA.
WITH THIS MOVE CAME EXCITEMENT
ANTICIPATION. WHEN BUT WHEN I
BEGAN LOOKING INTO THE SOCIAL
WORK REQUIREMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA IT BECAME
DISCOURAGING. THE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS WERE OVERWHELMING
ESPECIALLY WITH THE AMOUNT OF
EXPERIENCE AND TRAINING I HAD
JUST RECEIVED I WAS FURTHER
DISAPPOINTED WHEN I SAW THAT
ALTHOUGH THE PROCESS COULD BE
EXPEDITED THERE WAS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SUCH TIME
FRAME AND NO GUARANTEE ON THE
BOARDS PART. DESPITE MY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION
FROM THE STATE CALIFORNIA
REQUIRED THAT I COMPLETE AN
EXTENSIVE LIST OF REQUIREMENTS
DURING WHICH I WAS OPERATING AS
A SINGLE PARENT OF THREE.
DURING MY SPICES ABSENCE FOR
TRAINING AND PAGES UPON PAGES
OF TEDIOUS COMPLICATED
PAPERWORK. BUT BECAUSE MY
FAMILY RELIES ON MY ADDITIONAL
INCOME I BEGAN THE PROCESS IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS MY SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE
AS ONE OF THE ONLY BI LINGUAL
PROVIDERS IN THE AREA OR SIDE
OUT BY FACILITIES IN NEED
HOWEVER MY LACK OF LICENSE
MEANT THAT I COULD NOT ACCEPT.
THE SIX FIGURE SALARY OFFERS.
AFTER NINE MONTHS AND OVER ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN OUT OF
POCKET COST. ON APRIL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I FINALLY
OBTAINED MY CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T ALSO MENTIONED THAT MY
TRUE COST FAR EXCEED ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. BUT THAT
DOESN'T CAUGHT WHAT THAT COST
DOESN'T TELL YOU IS THAT THE
PREVIOUS SALARY THAT MADE ME
THE PRIMARY EARNER. WHO IS NO
LONGER FLOWING INTO OUR HOME.
BUT THEIR CLASSES AND TELL YOU
THAT A DEPLETED OUR SAVINGS AND
MY RETIREMENT FUNDS TO ENSURE A
FAMILY'S NEEDS WERE MET. SINCE
RECEIVING MY LICENSE I DECIDED
TO OPEN MY PRIVATE PRACTICE.
BECOME A PROVIDER FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA'S VICTIMS OF
CRIME PROGRAM. I HELP CHILDREN
AND ADULTS OVERCOME AND HE'LL
FROM THEIR TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES BY UTILIZING
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACHES. AND
MY CLINICAL BACKGROUND. I
BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT FOR YOU
TO KNOW WHAT I DO IN YOUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE FOR MONTHS
THIS PROCESS HAS HINDERED ME.
AND MANY LIKE ME. FROM ADDING
VALUE INTO THE COMMUNITIES WE
CALL OUR HOME EVEN ONLY FOR A
FEW YEARS. MY STORYIS NOT
UNIQUE MILITARY SPOUSES COME
FROM A DIVERSE RANGE OF
BACKGROUNDS ETHNICITIES
CULTURES EDUCATION AND
SPECIALTIES. MANY OF US
STRUGGLE TO FIND A CAREER OF
OUR OWN AMONGST THE
UNPREDICTABILITY AND CHALLENGES
OF BEING A MILITARY SPOUSE. I
WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM BUT I HAVE
COME HERE TODAY. TO ADVOCATE
FOR MILITARY SPOUSES. I DO THIS
IN HOPES THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER AND DEVELOP A PROGRAM
OR STREAMLINED THE SYSTEM. WELL
CLOSING THE GAPS TO HELP OTHERS
WHO WILL BE IN MY SHOES OVER
THE YEARS. THE CHANGE YOU MAKE
TODAY WILL LESSEN THE LOAD ON
THOSE WHO HAVE ALREADY GIVEN SO
MUCH. MILITARY LIFE CAN BE
DEMANDING BOTH FOR THE MILITARY
MEMBER AND THEIR FAMILY. WE
OPERATE OUR LIVES THE LIVES OF
OUR CHILDREN AT ANY MOMENT FOR
THE NEEDS OF THE MILITARY AND
OUR NATION. IT IS A
RESPONSIBILITY WE TAKE UPON
OURSELVES FREELY AND WITH
GRATITUDE. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE DO FOR OUR LOVE OF COUNTRY
AN HONOR TO THOSE BEFORE US. I
HOPE THE LEADERS IN THIS ROOM.
AND IN OUR NATION CAN FIND WAYS
TO FOSTER MUTUALLY AND
BENEFICIAL AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
STATE REGULATORY BOARDS IN AN
EFFORT TO LESSEN THE
CONSTRAINTS WE FEEL AND
PRACTICING ARE CHOSEN
PROFESSIONAL AND SERVING OUR
BASE COMMUNITIES. ALL WE ASK IS
AN EASIER PATH TO PURSUE OUR
OWN CAREER GOALS WELL OUR
SPOUSES SIR ALL WE ASK IS FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADD VALUE
INTO THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
WILL LIVE IN FOR THE COMING
YEARS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU. MISTRUST. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS HEARING TODAY I. CAME
HERE TODAY BECAUSE I LAUNCH THE
MILITARY'S FALLS PROFESSIONAL
NETWORK AT TRAVIS AIR FORCE
BASE WHICH HAS GROWN TO FOUR
HUNDRED MEMBERS IN LESS THAN
ONE YEAR NOW. I'M A MILITARY
SPOUSE MYSELF HAPPILY MARRIED
TO MY PARTNER IN LIFE WE HAVE
TWO WONDERFUL KIDS BUT WE HAVE
MOVED FOUR TIMES IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS. DURING THAT TIME
I'VE BEEN EITHER UNEMPLOYED OR
UNDEREMPLOYED. I'M HERE BECAUSE
I LOVE WHAT MY HUSBAND DOES
HOWEVER I'VE SEEN THAT THE
PATHS FOR PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME HAVE BEEN
ERASED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WITH EVERY. MOVE THIS IS A
TOPIC THAT. RELATES TO
RETENTION RECRUITMENT AND
RESILIENCE I MUCH MORE
RESILIENT WHEN I WORK A GIVES
ME A CHANCE TO FOCUS ON MY OWN
PROFESSIONAL GOALS IT IS
DRAINING AND DEPRESSING TO WAIT
FOR YOUR SPOUSE TO COME BACK
FROM FROM A DEPLOYMENT. AND.
MOST OF ALL A SECOND INCOME
GIVES US MUCH GREATER FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND ABILITY TO PLAN
FOR A BRIGHTER FUTURE. I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN DO A LOT
MORE FROM MILITARY SPOUSES
SEEKING MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT.
OR LAST SIX YEARS WE'VE LIVED
IN FOUR DIFFERENT STATES BEFORE
GETTING MARRIED I WORKED
INTERNATIONALLY IN P. ARMENIAN
EVENT MANAGEMENT WHEN WE- MET
IN FLORIDA IT WAS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER HOWEVER I WAS NOT ABLE
TO TEACH IN DC NEW JERSEY OR
CALIFORNIA. WE MOVED EVERY
TWELVE MONTHS IN THE PROCESS
AND COST INVOLVED WOULD BE TO
MUCH FOR ME TO TAKE ON. AFTER A
YEAR AND A HALF IN CALIFORNIA
FINALLY GOT A JOB AS AN
OPERATIONS MANAGER BEFORE THAT
I WAS A STAY AT HOME MOM.
DEFINITELY THE HARDEST JOB I'VE
EVER HAD WAS TO BE A STAY AT
HOME MOM. AND I NOW HAD TO QUIT
LAST MONTH BECAUSE WE HAVE
MOVED YET AGAIN AND I'M
CURRENTLY UNEMPLOYED. BASED ON
MY EXPERIENCE I WANTED TO HELP
OTHER SPOUSES GET TO A
MEANINGFUL JOB FASTER WHICH IS
WHY I STARTED UP THE MSDN
CHAPTER AT TRAVIS AIR FORCE
BASE. A SHORT STORY ABOUT WHO
WE ARE WE MET IN AUGUST LAST
YEAR THAT'S EXACTLY TWELVE
MONTHS AGO. WE ORGANIZE OUR
FIRST MEETING IN JUST UNDER TWO
WEEKS AND A CREW TO NOW FOUR
HUNDRED MEMBERS. IT DID NOT
TAKE LONG FOR ME TO REALIZE
THAT I WAS NOT ALONE. AT THIS
FIRST MEETING TWENTY FIVE
PEOPLE SHOWED UP ASKING THE
VERY SAME QUESTION HOW CAN WE
DO THIS MILITARY LIFESTYLE
BETTER. WE BECAME AN OFFICIAL
HIRING OUR HEROES AND THIS
PAEAN CHAPTER IN SEPTEMBER LAST
YEAR SO JUST A MONTH LATER. AND
WE ORGANIZE WE CONTINUE TO
ORGANIZE MONTHLY MEETINGS WITH
AT LEAST ONE EMPLOYER PRESENT
AND TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FIVE
SPOUSES WHO COME BACK EVERY
MONTH ASKING WHAT. MEANING FULL
JOB OPPORTUNITIES ARE THERE ARE
OUT THERE FOR ME. WE REPRESENT
THE DIVERSITY OF THE MILITARY
SPOUSE COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
AGE ETHNICITY PROFESSIONAL
BACKGROUND AND EDUCATION. AND
THE COLEY TEAM ALONE INCLUDES A
PHD CANCER SCIENTIST. THREE
COUNSELORS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS BEHAVIOR THERAPIST
POST PARTUM ARE AND TEACHERS IT
CONSULTANTS A STAND UP COMEDIAN
BANK TELLERS. SEVERAL STATE
HOME MOMS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. AS WE'VE ALL HEARD
MILITARY SPOUSES ARE VERY
TALENTED THEY POSSESS MORE
EDUCATION CREDITS THE MOST
WORKING AMERICANS YES
UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG MILITARY
SPOUSES IS FOUR TIMES HIGHER.
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
ESTIMATED BETWEEN SIXTEEN AND
24% I DID THAT I MUST BE IN
TRAVIS MEMBERS. ABOUT A QUARTER
THEM STRUGGLE WITH HER TO BEGIN
A CERTIFICATION OR LICENSURE
WHEN ARRIVING IN CALIFORNIA THE
TOP OBSTACLES ARE VERY SIMPLE
COST TIME AND PROCESS. THIS IS
A TOPIC THAT IS BUZZING IN THE
MILITARY SPOUSE COMMUNITY AS WE
WANT TO PUT OUR EDUCATION TO
USE AND EARN AN INCOME. I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF DANIEL SHE'S IN OUR
IN. SHE'S BEEN MARRIED TO MIKE
NOW FOR TWO YEARS THIS WAS DONE
A YEAR AGO THE SLIDE. AND THE
CALIFORNIA WAS OUR FIRST DUTY
STATION WHERE THERE ARE MOVING
FROM WASHINGTON STATE. THEY GOT
THEIR ORDERS IN AUGUST TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BUT IT WOULD
TAKE EIGHT MONTHS FOR. DANIEL
TO GET A JOB AS AN RN. EIGHT
MONTHS BEFORE SHE COULD START
WORKING. AN EARNINGS AS THAT
MUCH NEEDED SECOND INCOME. IT
WAS IT TOOK TH TILL OCTOBER OR
HER TO EVEN BE ABLE TO START
APPLYING BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
START APPLYING FOR JOBS UNTIL
SHE GOT HER LICENSE. I AND SHE
WAS FRUSTRATED WITH MULTIPLE
CLERICAL ERRORS ALONG THE WAY I
AND SHE RECOMMENDS THAT WHAT
CAN BE DONE IS ENSURING THAT
THE INSTRUCTIONS ONLINE OR
COMPLETE ENSURING THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE ASSOCIATES ARE WELL
TRAINED. FOR THE MILITARY
SPOUSE PROCESS AND CAN PROVIDE
CORRECT INFORMATION ALLOWING
THE APPLICATION DOCUMENTS TO BE
SUBMITTED ONLINE INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO WAIT TO BE DELIVERED.
I AND TO HAVE A NATIONALLY
ACCEPTED ARE IN LICENSE EVEN
TEMPORARY SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
START APPLYING FOR JOBS BEFORE.
ARRIVING THE MOMENT THEY GET
THEIR ORDERS. WHY A PASSION FOR
MILITARY SPOUSE EMPLOYMENT AS
MILITARY SPOUSES WE START FROM
SCRATCH EVERY TIME WE MOVE
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT FASTER AND
EASIER WILL GREATLY IMPACT
RETENTION RECRUITMENT AND THE
RESILIENCE OF. THIS
RECIPROCITY. CITY PAVES THE
PATHS OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
MILITARY SPOUSES AND GIVES US A
CHANCE TO BUILD A MUCH BETTER
AND BRIGHTER FUTURE AS MILITARY
FAMILIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
KEEPING THE CONVERSATION GOING.
THANK YOU FOR SHOULD SEND
ARRIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF WELL FIRST OF THE LAWYER
PIECE I OBVIOUSLY DON'T HAVE
THE DETAILS ON THE SUPERVISION
RULES WHICH IS WHY S. THE PER
PANEL THE QUESTIONS I DID I'M
GONNA TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE I
WOULD CERTAINLY AS THAT OF DID
YOU KEEP IN CONTACT WITH ME AND
THAT I WOULD ASK THE BAR
ASSOCIATION TO TOOK TAKE A LOOK
AT. THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY
HAVE FOR SPECIFIC SUPERVISION
BECAUSE SOME OF WHAT YOU
MENTIONED TO ME. CERTAINLY AT
SOME POINT GOES BEYOND WHAT AS
A MANAGING PARTNER OF A LAW
FIRM OR AS A PARTNER IN A LAW
FIRM I EVEN DID WITH RESPECT TO.
ASSOCIATES WITH SOME EXPERIENCE
SO WE'LL NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT. AS TO THE WAIVER IN AND
OF RULES AND OTHER STATES WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT THE MOST WE CAN
DO IN CALIFORNIA IS SAY THE
TIME SPENT. PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA IS A REGISTERED
SPOUSE ATTORNEY. COUNTS AS TIME
SPENT PRACTICING AS AN ATTORNEY
FOR ALL PURPOSES HERE. BUT IF
FOR EXAMPLE RESUMES A FEW WERE
TO MOVE TO SAN ANTONIO TEXAS IS
GOING TO HAVE TO. IN A PART OF
ITS ON THE OTHER STATE TO WRITE
BUT WILL HAVE TO WORK ON THAT
AND LASTLY. WHAT IMPACT IS THE
MALPRACTICE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
IN THE MALPRACTICE INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BOND ON THE
ISSUE OF SUPERVISION. OF A NON
LICENSED ATTORNEY PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA AND DOES THAT PLAY
ANY PART IN THE WAY THE. THE
BAR WILL HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT TO SEE WHETHER IT PLAYS
ANY PART IN THE WAY THE BARS OF
CO THE STATE BAR. OF DESIGNS
THE SUPERVISION RULES BUT I
COMMIT TO WORK ON THAT WITH YOU
BECAUSE I DO THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE TO SAY. USER FRIENDLY
PROGRAM AND WE NEED TO HOLD OF
MY POINT STARTING IN. JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THE MILITARY
SPOUSE LAWYERS. WHO CAME TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH A
DEGREE AND A LICENSE IN THE
STATE AND IN GOOD STANDING.
COULD STEP OUT AND WORK IN THE
STATE WELL A LOT OF
INTERRUPTION AND WITH A LOT OF
INTERFERENCE. FOR WHATEVER
PERIOD OF TIME FRANKLY FIVE I
AM PLEASED WITH FIVE YEARS. OF
THE STATE BAR WAS WILLING TO
PUT UP WITH. TO DECIDE WHETHER
OR NOT THIS THE SPOUSE FAMILY
WAS GONNA THAN MOVE OR STAY IN
THE STATE WHICH POINT YOU TAKE
THE BAR EXAM BUT I'M COMMITTED
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT SEE IF
WE CAN STRAIGHTEN THIS OUT. I
SAY ONE THING ON THAT QUICKLY I
HAVE NOT HEARD THAT THE
MALPRACTICE. THAT IS NOT COME
UP. AS AN ISSUE WITH OUR
MEMBERS AT LEAST SO. AND I'LL
STAY IN THE THIRTY EIGHT STATES
THAT NOW HAVE THESE RULES
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE INCIDENT
THAT I'M AWARE OF ANY
MISCONDUCT. I'M NOT SURE ISSUES
I'M NOT TOO GREAT WRITER WOULD
COMMIT MALPRACTICE BUT THERE'S
A REQUIREMENT TO HAVE
INSURANCE. RIGHT WHAT ANOTHER
IN THE AND THE QUESTION IS CAN
YOU GET IT AND HOW DO YOU GET
IT AND ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS.
RIGHT THE MENTOR SUPERVISOR
WHATEVER WE CALL HIM OR HER. IN
THE ARMS OF SECURING THAT SO
WE'LL HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT. AND AS TO THE OTHER
OCCUPATIONS WHAT WHAT DO YOU
SUGGEST. WE DO. TO SPEED THIS
PROCESS WAS JOHNSON YOU'VE
CERTAINLY HAD YOUR SHARE AND
MA'AM. I WAS MOVED BY YOUR
TESTIMONY WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MAKE THIS WORK. I THOUGHT FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE SLIDE WITH
RESPECT TO THE REGISTERED NURSE
THE NURSE NURSES TAKEN NATIONAL
EXAM OF THE- IN EXTRA NEXT TO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT THEY
TAKE COMING OUT OF A NURSING
SCHOOL. IN ORDER TO GET THEIR
LICENSE AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THEY'RE SO MUCH OF A
RIGMAROLE. GETTING THAT
PARTICULAR PERSON IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND IN A POSITION
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT PLACES
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS MAN
MAYBE YOU COULD SPEAK TO THAT.
RIGHT SO RECENTLY IN THE PAST I
BELIEVE TWO YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS ADOPTED THE NATIONAL EXAM
HOWEVER. IF WE ARE GONNA OBTAIN
OUR LICENSING CALIFORNIA WE DO
NEED TO PROVIDE A LINE ETHICS
EXAM WHICH SOME MIGHT ARGUE IS
AS EQUALLY AS CHALLENGING AS
THE BOARD EXAM AND IN MY CASE
FOR EXAMPLE I PLAY I AM. YOU
KNOW FAILING IS NOT AN OPTION
IT'S WE ARE ON A TIME CRUNCH
HERE AND SO I HAD TO PAY FOR
COURSE. TO PASS THIS EXAM
BECAUSE IT IS PRETTY RIGOROUS
ACCORDING TO THE FEEDBACK
PROVIDED BY OTHER LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER SEVERITY
OF THAT TAKING THE EXAM. SO
WHILE THERE IS A NATIONALLY
EXAM. ACROSS THE NATION
CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR OWN
STIPULATIONS AND THEIR OWN SET
OF REQUIREMENTS THAT WE ALL
HAVE TO ABIDE AND THERE IS.
THERE IS NO CONSIDERATION TAKEN
FOR MILITARY SPOUSES EXCEPT FOR
THE FACT THAT IT WILL BE
EXPEDITED AND EVEN IN THAT CASE
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE WHAT'S
AMAZING TO A LAW AND ETHICS
EXAM VERY IMPORTANT I SUPPOSE
WE NEED PEOPLE TO. UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS ARE
AND CERTAINLY TO BE ETHICAL BUT
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS WHY
WE CAN'T MOVE PEOPLE INTO A
POSITION AND ALLOW WORK TO BE
PERFORMED MUCH IS WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO DO HOWEVER
IMPERFECT ARE PERFECT MAY BE
WITH RESPECT TO LAWYERS. WHY WE
CAN'T ALLOW THAT FOR LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AS THE
REST OF THIS PROCESS CATCHES UP
AND IF YOU WANT TO PUT SOME
MENTORSHIP REQUIREMENTS ON IT A
NURSE CERTAINLY ALMOST ALWAYS
NOT ALWAYS BUT ALMOST ALWAYS
FUNCTIONS IN A GROUP. SETTING
OF HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
PERHAPS NOT SO MUCH WITH
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS BUT YOU COULD CERTAINLY
HAVE THAT HAPPEN AS WE MOVE
MILITARY SPOUSES INTO THESE
POSITIONS AND ALLOW THE
SUPPLEMENTAL TESTING IN. AND
ALL THAT TO CATCH UP WILL HAVE
TO WORK ON THAT. AND I GUESS
YEARS IS A TEACHING SITUATION
MA'AM I'M BAFFLED BY THE FACT
THAT SOMEONE WHO WAS A FRENCH
TEACHER. WE COULDN'T PUT TO
WORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE'LL HAVE TO GET ON THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU THANK YOU CENTER. JUST A
CLEVERNESS THIS TRAVEL DID YOU
ACTUALLY YOU GOT A JOB ON THE
BASE AS A SOCIAL WORKER NO I
HAVE A PRIVATE PRACTICE IN THE
CITY OF ROSEVILLE OKAY
SACRAMENTO YEAH I WAS OFFERED A
COUPLE JOBS ON BASE. AT THE
TIME I WAS A SINGLE MOM THREE
THAT CHILD CARE IS AN ISSUE
BEALE AIR FORCE BASES A VERY
RURAL COMMUNITY THE
ACCESSIBILITY TO JOBS AND
TRANSPORTATION AND CHILD CARE
IS VERY LIMITED THERE. AND SO
FOR ME MY OPTION CONSIDERING
I'M A MILITARY SPOUSE MY
HUSBAND'S JOB IS ALWAYS. FOR
EXAMPLE HE'S DEPLOYED. I NEEDED
TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN MY JOB
AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING I WAS
ABLE TO BE OFFERED IN AND
JUSTICE FOR FOLKS THE VIEW ON
HOW HOW. COMMON OR UNCOMMON IS
IT FOR THERE TO BE SUCH A GIVEN
THE FACT THE OF SO MANY
FAMILIES MILITARY FAMILIES
LIVING ON AROUND BASIS. WHAT IS
THE CHILD CARE SITUATION
TYPICAL TYPICALLY ON THESE
BASIS SO WE MET YESTERDAY WITH
THE MILITARY SPOUSE ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT ZONE IN SAN DIEGO
AND HAD SEVERAL FOLKS
DISCUSSING THE SITUATION THERE
WHICH IS THERE ARE TEARS. THE
BASED WILL FIRST I THINK IT WAS
TO ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS WITH
CHILDREN ALL HAVE PRIORITY THAN
A SINGLE SERVICE MEMBER HAS
PRIORITY AND RIGHT NOW THOSE
ARE THE ONLY TWO TEARS GETTING
INTO THE- CHILD CARE ON BASE IS
A SINGLE MOM WHOSE. SPOUSES
OVERSEAS IN THE COUNTRY BE
RIGHT IN THE MIX OF FACT MAYBE
EVEN HIGHER THAN THOSE ONES
BECAUSE THIRDS HERE IS A
SERVICE MEMBER WITH THE WORKING
SPOUSE AND AT THAT AND AS OF
YESTERDAY WE WERE TOLD THAT WAS
NOT BUT THEY WERE NOT BEING
ADMITTED TO THE ON BASE NOW
THERE ARE OPTIONS TO GO OFF
BASE AND SOME SUBSIDIES. WHICH
IS A WHOLE NOTHER ISSUE BUT
CHILD CARE CERTAINLY COMES OF
IT EVERY SPOUSE EMPLOYMENT
DISCUSSION WE GO TO. SEE TO ME
THAT WOULD BE IT WAS OUR. WELL
I DON'T KNOW IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER IMPORTANT
PRIORITY FOR DO YOU NEED TO
TAKE ON. YEAH I KNOW AND I MEAN
TO KEEP FLIPPING BACK TO YOU
BUT YOU ARE YOU'RE COMING TO US
ASKING FOR CHANGES WHICH I
THINK ARE APPROPRIATE. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THE DOD
IS DOING WHAT NEEDS TO DO. AND
SOMETIMES FORGETS THESE THINGS
IT SEEMS. HIS MERE CHILD CARE
IS A IT IS DEFINITELY AN ISSUE
BY. CHILD CARE CAN BE SOLVED
WITH. WITH THE SALARY. AND IN
IN MY CASE SEARCHING FOR A JOB.
PUT ME OUT OF POCKET BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T EFFECTIVELY SEARCH
FOR A JOB AND GO TO INTERVIEWS
WITHOUT PAYING FOR CHILDCARE
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO FIND THAT
CHILD CHILD CARE. AND YOU END
UP COMMITTING TO EITHER PAYING
FIFTEEN TO EIGHTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR. AND LOSING THAT MONEY.
FOR EVERY INTERVIEW THAT YOU GO
ON ANYTIME THAT YOU WANT TO
SEPARATE FOR THAT. THE JOB
SEARCH AND BUT WHEN I FINALLY
GOT A MEANINGFUL JOB WITH
ENOUGH OF A SALARY THAT PAYS
FOR MY CHILD CARE THAT'S- THAT
SOLVES THAT THAT URBAN. IT'S A
CHICKEN AND THE EGG SITUATION
FOR SURE RIGHT. YOU SHOULDN'T I
GUESS MY POINT IS IF YOU'RE IN
IN THIS TRAFFIC SITUATION
YOU'VE GOT THREE KIDS YOUR YOUR
SPOUSE'S OVERSEE SERVING THE
COUNTRY. AND WE OUGHT TO HAVE A
BETTER INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
TO HELP REGARDLESS OF. WHAT THE
MAKING A LOT OF MONEY OR NOT IN
A I MEAN THAT'S- THAT'S MY
FEELING IS THE- FATHER OF A TEN
MONTH OLD. I'M I'M JUST I MEAN
IN GENERAL I'M APPALLED BY HOW
LITTLE INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE
IN GENERAL FOR CHILD CARE
COMPARED TO COMPETITOR NATIONS
AND IT'S JUST THE POINTS BEEN
DRIVEN HOME WHEN MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE BUT- YEAH
WE PUT PEOPLE IMPOSSIBLE
SITUATIONS AT A YOU JUST LIKE
THAT CRAZY SITUATIONS YOU'RE
ALL. YEAH RAISING CONCERNS
ABOUT WITH REGARDS TO
CALIFORNIA'S LICENSOR RULES
THAT WE'RE GONNA TURN AGAIN
ADDRESSED. AND SOME. IN A I
JUST THINK IT'S ANOTHER THING
FOR US TO BE KIND OF
CONSIDERING BY THE WAY IF THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ME FULL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I OR YOU KNOW
WHATEVER EXISTING EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT EXIST ON
THE BASIS THAT WE COULD HELP TO
ASSIST WITH BY THE WITH THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. OR WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTORS PROVIDERS
OR AND OTHER PUBLIC SECTOR
PROVIDERS WE GOT A LOOK INTO.
THAT AS WELL. BECAUSE IN MOST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF FORM OF ANY SEE YOU
KNOW EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND. I DON'T
KNOW HOW IF THERE'S ENOUGH
CONVERSATION HAPPENING THERE
BUT YEAH MISTER I JUST WE
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
NOT ALL OF THESE MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS. ARE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE LOCATED IN URBAN
AREAS LIKE I SAN DIEGO AND- IF
YOU'RE AN EDWARDS AIR FORCE
SPACER AND AT BEALE. YOU CAN
YOU CONTROLLED GETTING FROM THE
POPULATED AREA TO THE MAIN GATE
LITERAL RIGHT. AND SO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO IF THE IF THE
MILITARY CHILD CARE FACILITY IS.
OVERSUBSCRIBED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CSUS SECURE ALTERNATIVE
CHILD CARE I WOULD IMAGINE. A
CAN BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT ALL
THE MORE REASON WHY WE NEED TO
HAVE BETTER FACILITIES ON BASS
AND LOGISTICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACCESS SO I JUST. AND IF I CAN
ADD ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
EMPLOY MILITARY SPOUSES SO THE
EASIER WE CAN MAKE IT FOR
SPOUSES TO BECOME CERTIFIED TO
BE A CHILD CARE PROVIDER. IN
CALIFORNIA KIND OF HIS SOLVING
TO PROBLEMS WITH. I'M AND MAYBE
IF THERE'S SOME YOU KNOW. I MAY
MEET ME IN A MAY MAYBE IF THE
ON BASE. I REMEMBER IF IT'S ON
BASE THERE IN A BECAUSE IT'S
NOT YOU KNOW FEDERAL FACILITY
THERE THAT ALSO CAN BE SOME
SORT OF STREAMLINING I DON'T
KNOW. BUT THAT'S ANOTHER THING
FOR US TO SPEND SOME TIME
LOOKING AT. THANK YOU GUYS
THANK YOU SO MUCH HE REALLY DID
A GOOD JOB OF I THINK
HIGHLIGHTING THE HUMAN STORIES
BEHIND THE- POLICY CHALLENGES
THAT WERE RAISED BY THE FIRST
PANEL. OKAY LET'S NOW HEAR FROM
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY. IN VARIOUS HAVE BEEN
OR ARE IN VARIOUS LEVELS OF
LEADERSHIP OF THE MILITARY OR
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
WE HAVE JOHN TEMAS HIS DEPUTY
TO THE GARRISON COMMANDER. IT'S
COMING OUT OF FOR WHEN I
BELIEVE RIGHT WITH THE US ARMY
I WE'VE GOT VICE ADMIRAL. AND
JUST RETIRED I SUPPOSE FROM
FROM. FROM THE US COAST GUARD
AND ABBAS ALSO SERVING AS VICE
CHAIR THE GOVERNOR'S MILITARY
COUNCIL WITHIN OUR JULY THAN
OTHERS. AND ROBERT HERRERA
WHO'S THAT WHO'S WITH OUR
CALVET. PROGRAM WORKING WITH MY
GOOD FRIEND DR IF I SEE ANY.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
YOUR PERSPECTIVES AS WELL IT'S
ALSO ON THE MILITARY COUNCIL
YES THAT'S RIGHT. YES YOU MAY
YOU MAY YOU MAY PROCEED.
CAROLINE BOB MEMBERS OF THE
STAFF AND OF THE TRICK
COMMITTING A GOOD AFTERNOON I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT AN ISSUE
THAT SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANCE TO
THE US ARMY. BUT WE'VE YOU
SPOUSE EMPLOYMENT AS A CRITICAL
ASPECT OVERALL RETENTION
EFFORTS. IT'S BEEN SAID THAT
YOU RECRUIT A SOLDIER BUT YOU
RETAIN A FAMILY. GIVEN THE
CURRENT CHALLENGES WE ARE IN
MANY THAT WE FACE OUR RETENTION
IS ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES. MY
NAME IS JOHN SIMMERS ON THE
DEPUTY GARRISON COMMANDER FOR
HER WHEN HOME OF THE NATIONAL
TRAINING CENTER. AND I LIKE THE
NAVY THE MARINE CORPS WHO
MAINTAINS A REGIONAL
HEADQUARTERS TO PRESENT ON
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES ARE THE
ARMY DOES NOT SERVE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LARGEST
ARMY INSTALLATION IN THE STATE.
I AM PLEASED TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. FOR THOSE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE NATIONAL TRAINING
CENTER IS PREMIER TRAINING
ACTIVITY IN UNITED STATES ARMY.
IT IS THE LARGEST OF THE ARMY'S
THREE COMBAT TRAINING CENTERS
OR SEE TC'S. BUT THE MISSION OF
THE CDC PROGRAM IS TO PROVIDE
REALISTIC JOINT AND COMBINED
ARMS COLLECTIVE TRAINING FOR
SOLDIERS LEADER STASSEN UNITS.
A IN ACCORDANCE WITH ARMY
ENJOYING DOCTRINE AT THE
NATIONAL TRAINING CENTER THE
PROBE FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON
TRAINING MECHANIZED BRIGADE
COMBAT TEAMS OR BC TEASE. WE'RE
THE ONLY MILITARY INSTALLATION
IN THE WORLD WE'RE BRIGADE
SIZED UNIT CAN TRAIN TOGETHER
AT A AND IS AS A COMBINED UNIT.
THE END YOU SEE TRAINING
EXPERIENCE AS AN INTENSE
PROGRAM IT'S NOMINALLY TWENTY
FOUR DAYS IN LENGTH BUT
ACTUALLY MUCH LONGER FOR THE
UNIT. THAT HAS. ASIAN AT THE
CONCLUSION OF TRAINING. NTC IS
TYPICALLY THE LAST EVENT IN THE
TRAINING PROGRESSION THAT
PREPARES UNITS FOR OVERSEAS
DEPLOYMENT WE ARE THOROUGHLY
FOCUSED ON MAKING UNITS BETTER
IN THE ANY MISTAKES MADE OR
WEAKNESSES IDENTIFIED RE
MEDIATED AT AND T. C. RATHER
THAN DOWN RANGE WHERE IT COUNTS
FOR REAL. AS I MENTIONED
TRAINING IS REALISTIC AND
INTENSE SENIOR ARMY LEADERSHIP
GAVE DIRECTION SOMETIME AGO TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THE UNIT HAS
QUOTE. A LIP QUIVERING
EXPERIENCE WALLET NTC. WHATEVER
WHAT BCT ARRIVES FOR TRAINING
GOOD THING OR BAD THING. THAT'S
A GOOD THING SIR. WHEN A BCT
ARRIVES FOR TRAINING IT BRINGS
FIVE THOUSAND TO SIX THOUSAND
SOLDIERS AN APPROXIMATE TWO
THOUSAND VEHICLES OUT TO T. AS YOU MAY EXPECT IN
ORDER TO TRAINING UNIT OF THAT
SIZE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
LAND IS REQUIRED. FOR URBAN
LOCATING THE HIGH MOJAVE DESERT
SAND BURNED YOU KNOW COUNTY HAS
AT LAND AVAILABLE. WE SAT ON
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES SURPRISE ME
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE MILES.
FOR PERSPECTIVE OUR TRAINING
AREA IS APPROXIMATELY THE SAME
SIZE AS THE STATE OF RHODE
ISLAND. THIS ENVIRONMENT
PROVIDES AN OPTIMAL TRAINING
EXPERIENCE ARE REMOTENESS
AMPLIFIES THE DIFFICULTIES ARMY
FAMILIES EXPERIENCE. DIFFICULT
ENOUGH FOR FREQUENT LOCATIONS A
MOVE TO FORT URBAN ADDS
COMPLEXITY TO THE SITUATION.
THE NEAREST CITY IS BAR STYLE A
SMALL AREA OF ONLY TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND RESIDENTS PROVIDING
ONLY LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SOLDIERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FORT IRWIN IS RECOGNIZED IN
ARMY REGULATIONS AS A QUOTE
REMOTE AND ISOLATED BASE ONE OF
ONLY A FEW IN THE CONTINENTAL
U. S. TO CARRY THAT DESIGNATION.
BECAUSE OF THIS THE FOR URBAN
LEADERSHIP IS KEENLY AWARE THAT
WE MUST PROVIDE A WELCOME
EXPERIENCE FOR THE SOLDIER AND
HIS OR HER FAMILY. THE BETTER
INSULATION IS TRULY THEIR
HOMETOWN COMMUNITY DURING THEIR
TOUR. I SAY ALL THIS TO GIVE
CONTEXT TO THE DISCUSSION IN
NEXT TEMP TO FRAME THE CURRENT
SITUATION FOR THE TYPICAL ARMY
SPOUSE IN REGARDS TO EMPLOYMENT.
ACCORDING TO THE US COUNCIL OF
ECONOMIC ADVISERS THE TYPICAL
MILITARY SPOUSE HAS MORE
EDUCATION IN THE OVERALL
CIVILIAN POPULATION. AROUND 40%
HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE IN NEARLY
75% HAVE SOME COLLEGE. THIS
CONTRASTS WITH THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION OF APPROXIMATELY 30%
WITH THE DEGREE AND ONLY 55%
WITH SOME COLLEGE. DESPITE THIS
HIGHER LEVEL OF EDUCATION
MILITARY SPOUSES ARE LESS
LIKELY TO BE IN THE LABOR FORCE
WHEN THE GENERAL WORKING AGE
POPULATION. 57% AS COMPARED
276% ACCORDING TO A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SURVEY. GIVEN
THAT LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION
TYPICALLY INCREASES WITH THE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION THE
DIFFERENCE IS ACTUALLY GREATER
THAN THOSE NUMBERS INDICATE.
FOR THE MILITARY SPOUSE THAT
SPOUSES THAT ARE IN THE LABOR
FORCE THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. THE EXACT
RATE IS DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
AS BEST MEN'S RANGE FROM A LOW
OF ONLY 10% TO A HIGH OF 24%
GIVEN THAT THE OVERALL
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS CURRENTLY
LESS THAN 4% THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT IS MUCH HIGHER FOR THE
MILITARY SPOUSE COMMUNITY THEN
FOR THE AVERAGE AMERICAN. THE
REASONS BEHIND THESE NUMBERS
ARE MARRIED. MANY MILITARY
SPOUSES CLAIM THEY CANNOT FIND
RELIABLE CHILDCARE. HOWEVER IN
MANY CASES THE REASON IS DUE TO
THE POOR OUTLOOK FOR THE
MILITARY SPOUSE LOOKING FOR
EMPLOYMENT. MILITARY SPOUSES
FACE TO FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
WHEN IT COMES TO FINDING
EMPLOYMENT. FREQUENT RELOCATION
EVERY TWO TO THREE YEARS ON
AVERAGE MEANS THAT THERE ARE
LIKELY TO BE GAPS IN THEIR
RESUMES ALONG WITH NUMEROUS
JOBS HELD WE SHORT TENURES. IF
NOT SCREENED OUT WITHOUT EVEN
AN INTERVIEW SPOUSES ARE OFTEN
ASK QUESTIONS SUCH AS- WHY HAVE
YOU MOVED AROUND SO MUCH FOR
WHEN WILL YOU MOVE AGAIN.
CREATING CONSCIOUS OR NOT A
BIAS AGAINST HIRING MILITARY
SPOUSES. EMPLOYERS FIELD THE
SPOUSE CAN MOVE AGAIN ON SHORT
NOTICE AND THEY'RE NOT WILLING
TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT NOW. THE
RESULT IS THAT IN ADDITION TO
LOW LABOR FORCE PARTICIPATION
AND HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT. MORE
THAN HALF OF THE MILITARY
SPOUSES WHO ARE WORKING SAY
THEY ARE IN A POSITION THAT
THEY ARE OVER QUALIFIED FOR AND
AS A RESULT THE TYPICAL
MILITARY SPOUSE EARNS 26% LESS
THAN THEIR NON MILITARY PEERS.
A DIFFERENCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
INCOME LOSS TO THOSE MILITARY
FAMILIES. THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL FATE ISSUE FACING
MILITARY SPOUSES AS A SEEK
EMPLOYMENT THAT I WANT TO FOCUS
ON FOR A MOMENT. OF THE
MILITARY SPOUSES WHO DO WORK
NEARLY 35% REQUIRE PROFESSIONAL
LICENSE TO MAINTAIN THEIR
STATUS IN ABILITY TO WORK IN
THEIR CHOSEN CAREER FIELD.
INCLUDING A PRICE WE 19% IN THE
HEALTHCARE FIELD AND
APPROXIMATELY 10% IN THE
EDUCATION FIELD. SIGNIFICANTLY
THOSE LIGHTS IS OFTEN DO NOT
TRANSFER ACROSS STATE LINES. A
MAJOR ISSUE CONSIDER THAT A
MILITARY FAMILY IS
APPROXIMATELY TEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO MOVE ACROSS STATE
LINES THAT ARE NON MILITARY
FAMILY. I'LL GIVE A REAL LIFE
EXAMPLE OF WHAT THIS USED TO
MEAN. THERE'S A SPOUSE OF A
SOLDIER CURRENTLY AT FORT OR IN
WHO WORKS AS A SCHOOL TEACHER.
UPON THAT FAMILIES INITIAL
POTION TO BORDER ON SOME YEARS
AGO. SHE WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF OBTAINING A
CALIFORNIA TEACHER CREDENTIAL A
PROCESS THAT INVOLVES MULTIPLE
TESTS OTHER REQUIREMENTS.
SUBSEQUENTLY SHE LEFT THE STATE
HER HUSBAND WAS POSTED TO
DIFFERENT INSTALLATION. SHE
WENT ABOUT A CHENEY TEACHER
CREDENTIAL IN THAT STATE AND
LET HER CALIFORNIA CREDENTIAL
EXPIRE. AS LUCK WOULD HAVE IT
AFTER SOME OTHER TOWARDS A DUTY
THE FAMILY RETURNED AFFORD OR
WHEN. SINCE SHE A LETTER
CREDENTIAL THAT SHE HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS
AGAIN. TAKING MULTIPLE TASKS
AND SPENDING OVER A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO GET RE CERTIFIED.
CURRENTLY TO ENSURE TO SHE DOES
NOT HAVE TO REPEAT THIS PROCESS
EVER AGAIN SHE NOW MAINTAINS
CURRENT TEACHING CREDENTIALS IN
FOUR DIFFERENT STATES. JUST IN
CASE HER HUSBAND'S CAREER TAKES
HER TO ONE OF THOSE PLACES
AGAIN. OF COURSE THIS WILL NOT
HELP IF HE GETS AN ASSIGNMENT
IN THE STATE WHERE THEY HAVE
NOT LIVED BEFORE. FOR URBAN
REMOTE INSTALLATION THERE ARE
FOUR SCHOOLS ON BOARD THE BASS.
NOTED THESE ARE NOT DIFFER
PARTNER DIFFERENT SCHOOLS
RATHER DISTRICT IN STATE
SCHOOLS ARE SITUATED ON THE
INSTALLATION. AT THE SCHOOLS
ARE PRICE BY 25230% OF THE
STAFF OR MILITARY SPOUSES. MOST
OF WHOM REQUIRE CREDENTIAL SO
YOU CAN SEE THE IMPACT THESE
PROGRAMS. WE DO RECOGNIZE A
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENTS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IN REGARDS TO SIMPLIFY
THE PROCESS OF RETAINING
CREDENTIAL. ESPECIALLY FOR
TEACHERS BUT ALSO FOR OTHER
PROFESSIONS. AS WELL WE'RE
THANKFUL FOR THESE IMPROVEMENTS
BEANIE TWO THOUSAND TEN
NUMEROUS LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS FOR ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY AND VETERANS AS
WELL AS SPOUSES. INCLUDING VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN FOR TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. HOWEVER WE
RESPECTFULLY BELIEVE THAT
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS CAN BE MADE.
RECENTLY IN BOTH ARIZONA AND
UTAH CHANGES WERE MADE TO ALLOW
A MILITARY SPOUSE TO WORK IN
THAT STATE. BASED ONLY UPON
HAVING A LICENSE IN GOOD
STANDING FROM ANY OTHER STATE.
THIS IS A GOOD AND STATE THAT
WOULD BE DESIRABLE CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH WE RECOGNIZE THE
OBSTACLES IT MAY PREVENT SHORT
TERM IMPLEMENTATION. THERE ARE
OTHER MEASURES MEASURES WE
BELIEVE CAN BE ENACTED IN THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. AND CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE SHORT TERM.
THESE INCLUDE. IN THESE HAVE
BEEN TOUCHED ON BEFORE BUT I DO
WANT TO REPEAT ABU FIRST
JOINING THE INTERSTATE COMPACTS
ON OCCUPATIONAL LICENSURE THAT
ALREADY EXIST FOR MANY
HEALTHCARE FIELDS. SECOND
PROVIDING LICENSURE BY
ENDORSEMENT FOR RECOGNITION FOR
OUT OF STATE LICENSE ESPECIALLY
AS A TEMPORARY MEASURE WHILE
ALLOWING NEWLY ARRIVED FAMILY
MEMBERS TO OBTAIN THE FULL
REQUIRED CREDENTIALS. THE THIRD
EXEMPTING MILITARY SPOUSES FOR
THE REQUIREMENT FOR WHAT'S
CALLED CONTINUOUS OR
IMMEDIATELY PRIOR EXPERIENCE
SINCE AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
THE MILITARY LIFESTYLE CAN MAKE
THIS REQUIREMENT CHALLENGING.
AND FINALLY OUR FOR A WAIVER OF
LICENSURE FEES AN EXPEDITED
EXPEDITED EDUCATION FOR ALL
APPLICATIONS IN OUR CAREER
FIELDS. ANY MOVEMENT ON THESE
OR OTHER SIMILAR INITIATIVES
THAT HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE LIVES OF OUR SOLDIERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND IN
PARTICULAR A HELP TO ENABLE
BETTER EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MILITARY SPOUSES. WOULD BE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK TODAY NUMBER HALF THE
FORD OR COMMUNITY AND THE ARMY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SURE. OKAY HOME NEXT YEAR WITH
FROM BY FEDERAL BROKERAGE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALLEN SENATOR ROTH
COULD SEE YOU AGAIN SIR STAFF
IT'S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
I RETIRED AFTER SERVING THIRTY
FOUR YEARS ON ACTIVE DUTY IN
THE UNITED STATES COAST GUARD
WHICH I WOULD NOTE IS AN ARM
SERVICE BUT IT'S NOT PART OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IT IS
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY SO IT'S NOT
ONLY MILITARY TIMES OF WAR
REYES OR HAS THAT WORK THAT.
THAT THERE IS A LAW THAT THAT
PROVIDES FOR THAT I THINK SINCE
SECURITY STOOD UP AND WITH THE
IT'S A PROFILE OR PORTFOLIO OF
RESPONSIBILITIES I DO NOT SEE
THAT THE COAST GUARD WOULD EVER
AGAIN MOVE UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE. AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY COUNCIL I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST TECHNOLOGY
GROUP THAT IS HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE ARE WHO ARE TERRIFIC
PARTNERS WORKING ON A WHOLE
ARRAY OF ISSUES WITH US ON THE
COUNCIL IN IN THAT IT ARE THAT
IS THAT WE HAVE MEMBERS OF THE
DEFENSE SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
THOSE LEADERS WHO ARE FROM THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN
PROXIMITY TO OUR BASES ACROSS
THE STATE AND THIS IS A VERY
VERY ACTIVE GROUP WHOSE
PARTNERSHIP WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. I THANK THEM FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND FOR
AFFORDING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. IT IS AN ISSUE
OF SUCH IMPORT TO THE MILITARY
THAT THE SERVICE SECRETARIES
JOINTLY SIGNED A LETTER. TO THE
NATIONAL GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NOTING THIS IS ONE OF THEIR TOP
TWO PRIORITIES. AND ONE WHICH
WOULD IMPACT BASING AND
RESOURCING DECISIONS AND IF YOU
HAVE NOT HEARD RECENTLY. THESE
ISSUES HAVE BECOME PART OF THE
SCORING CRITERIA FOR MISSIONS
THAT WILL AFFECT RESOURCING.
I'M HONORED TO COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND BRING SEVERAL
DIFFERENT LENSES TO THIS ISSUE.
AS THE DETAILER AND THEN HEAD
OF MY SERVICES OFFICER
ASSIGNMENTS SYSTEM MY
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND THE
STRESS FRUSTRATION AND FAMILY
IMPACT SPOUSAL CREDENTIALING
CHALLENGES CREATED. AND PART OF
MY RESPONSE TO OUR CHAIR
GLAZIER WOULD HAVE BANNED WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE IMPACT IT
IMPACTS THE SERVICE'S ABILITY
TO ASSIGN PEOPLE. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT I RETURN ROUTINELY
HEARD THAT PEOPLE LOVE WHO NEED
LICENSING AND CREDENTIALING THE
FAMILIES DID NOT WANT TO MOVE
TO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF ITS
REPUTATION IN THIS ARENA. AS
OPERATIONAL COMMANDER IN
ONGOING MENTOR I EXPERIENCE
CONTINUE TO SEE THEM DOWN AND
WAITS A MILITARY MAN ABILITY TO
FOCUS ON THEIR MISSION. ONCE HE
LEFT THE SERVICE MY HUSBAND
BECAME OF THAT MERION SO I
LIVED THIS EXPERIENCE. AND
LASTLY IS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY COUNCIL I
CONTINUE TO HEAR THE IMPACT ON
SERVICE MEMBERS THEIR FAMILIES
BASES BUSINESSES AND ALSO THE
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
REPUTATION. MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. WHEN I FIRST BECAME
A FLAG OFFICER I RECEIVED
ORDERS TO CALIFORNIA. I HAD TO
REPORT AND SHORT TERM WELL
BEFORE THE END OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR SO I MOVED AHEAD OF MY
FAMILY. MY HUSBAND HAD TO MOVE
OUR FAMILY. FIND TEMPORARY
QUARTERS WHEN HE SHOWED UP AND
WAS INFORMED HOUSING WASN'T
READY GET OUR KIDS STARTED ON
THEIR SPORTS TEAM WHICH IS THE
VEHICLE WE USE FOR OUR CHILDREN
TO INTEGRATE INTO NEW
COMMUNITIES AND TO HAVE FRIENDS
WHEN SCHOOL STARTED GET OUR
CHILDREN ENROLLED IN SCHOOL-WERE NEEDED PROOF OF RESIDENCE.
AND THEN GET OUR HOUSEHOLD
GOODS DELIVERED AND SETTLED
INTO OUR HOME. AT THIS TIME I
WAS OVERSEAS AND SPECIALIZED
TRAINING WELL MY HUSBAND DEALT
WITH THIS. UP TO THIS POINT ALL
OF THE MOVES TO MY SPOUSE'S
THAN SEVENTEEN YEARS AS A
VETERINARIAN AT BENCHES STATES
WITH RECIPROCITY USUALLY
REQUIRING TAKING A TEST ON THE
STATE HEALTH LAWS. AND
CALIFORNIA MY HUSBAND WAS
REQUIRED TO FIND A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE VETERINARIAN. VOLUNTEER
FORTY HOURS TO THAT
VETERINARIAN SO THAT HE COULD
BE ASSESSED AND THEN SPONSORED
FOR LICENSING HERE'S SOME
REQUIRED TO TAKE A ONE WEEK
COURSE THAT WAS OFFERED IN LOS
ANGELES ONCE A YEAR. IN THE
SPRING. MOST MILITARY FAMILIES
MOVE OVER THE SUMMER. THAT WAS
MY SPOUSE'S WELCOME TO
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT HE
DECIDED NOT TO PRACTICE WHICH
WAS AN OPTION FOR US.
ULTIMATELY AFTER VOLUNTEERING
AT MARIN HUMANE SOCIETY HE DID
GET HIS CALIFORNIA LICENSE AND
STARTED WORK HE TAUGHT ADVANCED
SURGICAL SKILLS TO THE STAFF
AND ULTIMATELY DID HIMSELF OUT
OF A JOB BY ESTABLISHING A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE SOCIETY
AND THE DAVIS VETERINARY SCHOOL
SHELTER MEDICINE PROGRAM.
RESULTING IN THE HIGHER OF A
GRADUATE OF THAT PROGRAM AND HE
MOVED ON TO OTHER SHELTERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. SERVICE JOBS NO
I SHARE THIS EXPERIENCE
ALTHOUGH IT'S A LITTLE DATED
FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS FIRST
AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD MY
HUSBAND'S EXPERIENCE IN OUR
FAMILIES IS NOT UNIQUE.
FORTUNATELY WHAT HE EXPERIENCED
NOT BE THE EXPERIENCE FOR OF
THAT MERION COMING TO
CALIFORNIA TODAY THAT LICENSING
BOARD HAS A VERY EASY TO USE
WEBSITE WITH THE SPECIFIC
BUTTON FOR MILITARY SPOUSES AND
ONE FOR TRANSITIONING MILITARY
AND ALSO OFFERS TEMPORARY
LICENSES. SECOND THIS WAS MY
HUSBAND'S WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA
HIS FIRST IMPRESSION THAT
IMPRESSION IS LASTING AS
MILITARY MOVES AROUND AND IT IS
AN IMPRESSION THAT IS ACTIVELY
SHARED. FURTHER. EVERYONE
ULTIMATELY LEAVES ACTIVE DUTY
THE IMPRESSION IMPACTS
DECISIONS TO SEAT POST SERVICE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIRD WE HAVE A
SAYING IN THE MILITARY LEAVE A
UNIT BETTER THAN YOU FOUND IT
THAT IS WHAT MY SPELLS AND
OTHER MILITARY SPOUSES DO THEY
FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM WE FLEX ON
THE SERVICES AND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OTHER VETS AND SPOUSES.
THEY BRING A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AND BROADEN
NETWORKS THE QUITE FRANKLY
BENEFIT CALIFORNIA. THE
MILITARY COUNCILS FIRST
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS ISSUE WAS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WORKING WITH
EDWARDS AIR FORCE BASES SENATOR
RALPH MAY REMEMBER. WE BECAME
AWARE OF TEACHER SHORTAGES IN
THE SCHOOL SUPPORTING THE BASE
AND THAT THERE WERE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS AMONG THE MILITARY
SPOUSES WHO COULD NOT GET
CREDENTIALED IN THE STATE. THE
STUDENT MAKES ALONG WITH OTHERS
WE ENGAGED AND TODAY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES BEEN MADE
TO JOIN TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PROCESS IS BE YOU HAVE HEARD
MISMATCHES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION. THE
NATIONAL SECURITY FOUR POINT IN
OUR STATE IS LARGE RIVALING
EVER CULTURE IN ITS ECONOMIC
IMPACT AND LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
RANKED NUMBER ONE AND
CONTRACTOR DOLLARS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
WORKFORCE IS KEY TO THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE OF THIS AND ANY
STATE. WE HAVE HEARD FROM
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE OF
THE CHALLENGES AND HIRING
PREDOMINANTLY STEM WHICH AND
WHICH INCLUDES LICENSED
SPECIALISTS. AND THOSE WERE
SECURITY CLEARANCES. OUR STATE
FOOTPRINT AS YOU HAVE HEARD
INCLUDES ONE OF THE MOST
PROLIFIC ARRAY OF LABS TESTING
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS RANGES AND
DEPOSE OF ANY STATE. THE WORK
FORCES OF THESE LOCALES ARE
HIGHLY CIVILIAN EYES COMPRISED
OF SCIENTISTS LAB OPERATORS
ENGINEERS AND OTHERS. MOST ARE
LOCATED IN REMOTE LOCATIONS
THAT MANY CIVILIANS AS YOU
REFER TO FOR HER WHEN ARE NOT
DRAWN TO. THIS ALSO CHALLENGES
THERE ARE THIS ALSO CAUSES
CHALLENGES AND SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES.
LICENSING AND CREDENTIALING
PROCESSES TEND TO TAKE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH NOT
RECOGNIZING THAT MORE RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE SOMETIMES MORE
ADVERSELY IMPACTED. MEASURES
SUCH AS TEMPORARY LICENSES
CREEK FLEXIBILITY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF BUSINESSES AND
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS NOT A ONE
SIDED ISSUE THAT ONLY BENEFITS
THE TRANSITIONING MILITARY AND
SPOUSES IT IS GOOD BUSINESS AND
HUMAN CAPITAL PRACTICE. ARE
TRANSITIONING MILITARY AND
SPOUSES BRING IN A RAY OF
EXPERIENCE FROM NEW TO THE WORK
FORCE TO DEEP EXPERIENCE EITHER
TECHNICALLY OR ORGANIZATIONALLY
AND COVER MANY PRISON
PROFESSIONS AGAIN WHICH YOU
HAVE HEARD. WE ARE MISSING
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
FULLY LEVERAGE THE TALENT
AVAILABLE TO DRIVE OUR ECONOMY
AND WE ARE CERTAINLY MISSING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LET THIS
TALENT KNOW THAT WE WANT THEM
TO REMAIN. RETURN OR TO SEEK
SEEK OUT POST SERVICE
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ONLY GET ONE CHANCE TO MAKE A
FIRST IMPRESSION. WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE IN
COMPETITION FOR TALENT AND THAT
OTHER STATES HAS STEPPED OUT
AGGRESSIVELY AND RESPONSIVE THE
SERVICE SECRETARIES LETTERS.
THOSE EFFORTS ARE NOTED IN THE
PENTAGON AND COAST GUARD
HEADQUARTERS AND WITHIN THE
SERVICE COMMUNITIES. THERE HAVE
BEEN STEPS FORWARD THE
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY STILL
HAS A REPUTATION FOR BEING A
DIFFICULT STATE FOR LICENSING
AND CREDENTIALING. THE MILITARY
COUNCIL DID ITS OWN ASSESSMENT
LAST YEAR ON CREDENTIALING
PORTABILITY AND IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES TODAY WE ARE INFORMED
BY THE BEST PRACTICES SAYS
MEANT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND EFFORTS IN
OTHER STATES SUCH AS HAVING A
POINT PERSON WHO UNDERSTANDS
THE DD TWO FOURTEEN IN THE
MILITARY LIFESTYLE TO WORK
WITHIN THIS COMMUNITY. I
APPLAUD THE SELF ASSESSMENT
CONDUCTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND THE
EFFORTS OF OTHER LICENSING
BOARD SUCH AS THE VETERINARY
LICENSING BOARD TO OPEN UP
THEIR PROCESS SEES. I'M ACCOUNT
SO WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THEM TO ADVANCE THIS ISSUE
AND IN FACT TOMORROW WE HOLD
THE STATE WIDE DEFENSE SUMMIT.
WHICH INCLUDES MILITARY LEADERS
AND DEFENSE SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
FROM ACROSS THE STATE WE ARE
HOLDING TWO PANELS ON THIS VERY
ISSUE AND WILL BE CREATING AN
ACTION PLAN FROM THAT FORUM. SO
HOW MUCH PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
MUCH REMAINS TO BE DONE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
INTEREST THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY NO FIVE YEAR
FROM ROB RIVER TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR THERE
ROTH. SO I'D LIKE TO THANK A
AND YOU KNOW THIS THE SIDE THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING THE
CALIFORNIA FAR BETTER FAIRS
HERE TODAY FOR A LOT ABOUT YOU
ACTIVE DUTY MEMBERS AND THEIR
SPOUSES AND YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO START MY TESTIMONY WITH
WITH THE PERSONAL. PERSONAL
STORY. I GOT A SERVICE IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN AND- MY WIFE
WAS THE- PHARMACY TECHNICIAN.
I'M WORKING IN FLORIDA FOR
NATIONAL OF RETAIL PHARMACY
CHAIN. AND THE MORE I THINK
ABOUT IT AND I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO LIVE TESTIMONY
TODAY FROM INDIVIDUALS THE MORE
I REALIZE HOW CRITICAL. THE
ABILITY FOR MY WIFE AS PHARMACY
TECH BEING HAVING A NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION ON HOW CRITICAL
THAT WAS IN A MEETING OUR
TRANSITION WHEN WE GOT OUT. AND
WHEN WE CAME BACK TO CALIFORNIA
TO. PURSUE OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
IN THE STATE. OF HER ABILITY TO
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN WORKING. MADE
THAT VERY STRESSFUL TIME. OF A
MUCH EASIER. AND AT THAT TIME
WHEN I WAS GETTING ON THE
SERVICE YOU KNOW THE- DOT HAVE
THE TRANSITIONS THE T. GPS
COURSE AVAILABLE. AND LOOKING
REFLECTING ON ON NOT EXPERIENCE
GOING THROUGH TOPS ON AND
INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW THAT
INFORMED MY. OUR MY SPOUSE NUYS
A TRANSITION FROM MILITARY
SERVICE INTO CIVILIAN LIFE I'M
I'M VERY EXCITED THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANSAFFAIRS I'M WORKING IN
A SIDE BY SIDE WITH THE D. O.
D. AND WITH THE SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MILITARY COUNCIL
HAVE THIS CAL TOP PROGRAM. ALL
THAT HAS BEEN OPERATING ON
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS NOW
ACROSS THE STATE FOR ABOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF AND THAT'S
WE'RE OFFERING A TWENTY FOUR
INSTALLATIONS AT THE MOMENT AND
BASICALLY. THE CALIPERS OF
COURSE LEGISLATING BY A. B.
FIFTEEN OH NINE. REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE A
TRANSITION PROGRAM THAT
COMPLEMENTS THE DOD PROGRAM AND
WE WERE LOOKING AT HOW WE WERE
GOING TO. BEGIN IMPLEMENTING
THIS THIS NEW CAL TAP PROGRAM.
A YOU KNOW FIRST WE WANT TO
LOOK WHAT WERE THE GAPS WITH IN
BY THE TI GPS COURSE THAT WE'VE
RELEVANT TO. A SERVER MEMBERS.
SEPARATING OUGHT TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND TWO KEY AREAS
THAT WE IDENTIFIED WERE THE
ABILITY TO REALLY SIT DOWN AND
HAVE AND HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION WITH WITH THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT ON A
PARTICULAR TOPIC. AS WELL AS-
THE NEED FOR A CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC INFORMATION. AND
ENDING EXAMPLE LIKE O GIVE OF
THAT. IS YOU KNOW DO GENERALLY
T. G. P. S. I WHEN IT COMES TO
LET'S JUST SAY YOUR GI BILL. A
THIS IS THE FEDERAL TRANSITION
PROGRAM. WE'LL GO OVER HERE
THIS IS YOU GI BILL THIS IS YOU
BENEFITS IS HOW YOU SIGN UP
THIS IS BE AGE THIS IS HOW
USEFUL THIS IS THE BE A **** TO
SCHOOL TOOL IT'S VERY IT'S VERY
GENERAL AND HAS TO BE THAT WAY
BECAUSE IT NEEDS TO REACH A
NATIONAL AUDIENCE. IN CAL TOP.
OF WE BRING IN SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERT FROM LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS WELL AS YOUR OWN
STAFF. AND PROVIDE INFORMATION
SUCH AS THIS IS A CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE THIS IS THE
CSU THIS IS THE UC THIS IS HOW
YOU TRANSFER THIS IS WHAT G. E.
IS THIS IS I GUESS SEE. AND IT
MAKES IT DODD THESE ARE BEST
PRACTICES THE OTHER STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE EMPLOYED ON TO
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR
TRANSITION IN IN THE AND WHAT
WHETHER IT'S EDUCATION
IMPLEMENT SERVICES WE PARTNER
WITH WORK FOR WARRIORS OTHER
OTHER MILITARY DEPARTMENT. AND
DCA WITH OUR OFFICE TO NAY
RELIEF ON THEY PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON EATING A SOON TO
BE VETERANS ON GENERAL FIVE
GENERAL GUIDELINES ON SELECTING
SCHOOL MAKING SURE THEY
UNDERSTAND DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
PRIVATE. INSTITUTION A. PUBLIC
INSTITUTION WHAT WHAT HOW HOW
DID ENGAGE WITH A PROPRIETARY
INSTITUTION IF YOU FEEL YOUR IN
A PREDATORY ENGAGEMENT AND
WELLS AS WELL AS INFORMATION
REGARDING LICENSURE AND
EXPEDITING OF LICENSES. FOR
VETERANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO. HI AND THEN IN
THE IN THE AFTERNOON SESSION WE
ALSO ALLOW. WE ALLOW OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS WHO AND THEIR
FAMILIES IF THEY CHOOSE TO TOWN
TO ACTUALLY HAVE THESE ONE ON
ONE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS THAT ARE
IN THE ROOM THAT PRESENTED SO
WHETHER THAT'S- APRIL OAKLEY'S
TEAM WHO WHO PRESENTED EARLIER
TODAY. WHETHER THAT'S A
REPRESENT FROM COMMUTING COSTS
WHETHER THAT'S ON THE RIVERS OF
WORK FOR YEARS ARE GIVING THAT
TO GIVEN THAT TIME ON TO REALLY
ASK PERSONAL QUESTIONS THE
COURSE NO ONE IS GOING TO SIT
THERE IN A CLASSROOM WHEN THE
WHEN THE HOME LOAN.
PRESENTATIONS GOING SAY HI I
HAVE. CREDIT HOW CAN YOU HELP
ME. SO ALLOWS FOR A LITTLE BIT
MORE ENGAGED IN THAT
CONVERSATION. SO THE SECOND CUT
OUT REACH PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
OUT CAL THAT THAT GOES BEYOND
THE DOD INSTALLATIONS. COLOR
LOCAL INTERESTING NETWORK
COORDINATOR PROGRAM I'M I'M
SURE MISTER CHAIR AND CENTER
ROTH YOU'VE INTERFACE WITH WITH
OUR LINKS IN THE PAST. AND
THEIR THEIR ROLE IS TO ACT AS
ENTRY POINTS INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THAT OUR
SERVICES IN THEIR SIGNED REGION
WITH EIGHT LINKS. EACH HAVE A
SIGN GEOGRAPHIC REGION OF
ROUGHLY A COMPRISING ROUGHLY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND VETERANS
SOME MORE SOME LESS. AND THEIR
THEIR ROLE IS TWO FOLD A. IF
VETERAN PRESENTS AN ISSUE THEY
HAVE A MATTER THEY NEED ADDRESS
HEY YOU KNOW I JUST GOT THIS
THIS IS A DETERMINATION LETTER
FROM THE VA WANT TO APPEAL IT
WHAT DO I DO TOO I'M LOOKING
FOR HOUSING SERVICES WHAT DO I
DO. OR HEY. YOU KNOW I'D I'D
I'D LIKE I'D LIKE TO YOU TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS FOR THIS
LICENSE WHY DO AND. SO THERE
THEIR JOB IS TO UNDERSTAND THE
TOTALITY OF VETERANS BENEFITS
AND SERVICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
UNDERSTAND. OF WHO THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE IN THE REGION A
COMMUNITY BASED SYSTEM OF CARE
THAT EXIST THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND HOW CAN WHERE IS THE
MOST EFFICIENT PLACE TO PLACE
THAT VETERAN WITH IN. THAT THAT
COMMITTEE BASED SYSTEM OF CARE.
SO FIVE THAT'S A THAT'S A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF OUR OF OUR OUR OUR-
TWO MAIN OUT REACH PROGRAMS.
THAT CAL THAT. AND ONE THING
THAT I JUST I JUST WANTED SAN
GENERAL'S YOU KNOW. THIS
APPARATUS THAT'S IN PLACE IT
IT'S VERY FLEXIBLE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WILLING TO SHARE MORE
INFORMATION. BEING A REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS THAT WE
DO HOW WE DO IT TO. MEET THE
NEEDS OF YOU KNOW THIS VERY. OF
A CRITICAL COMPONENT. OF OUR
OUR SERVICE MEMBERS VETERANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WHICH IS OF
COURSE. THE SPOUSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOU SO MUCH. OKAY
ANY. FOUND QUESTIONS WERE READ
A LITTLE OVER BUT BUT THIS IS
ALL VERY MEATY AND VERY HELPFUL
AND I THINK WE'RE ALL GOING TO.
HAVE TO SPEND A LITTLE TIME TO
SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP WITH
WITH THAT WITH THIS. VENOMOUS
IMPORTANCE AT ISSUE SO I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
AND WE'RE IN TOUCH WITH YOU AND
AS WE MOVE FOR WITH THE POLICY
SOLUTIONS. THE PROJECT THAT I'M
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT FOLKS ONE IN
RECENT CONCERNS OR ISSUES YES.
AB FIVE HIM SHE COULD. SERVICE
YEAH GO FOR IT YEAH. A LOT OF.
I THINK THIS IS A NUMBER.
CALIFORNIA AND I LOVE COMING
MAYBE SHE HAS A TREMENDOUS
RESOURCE WE HAVE A LOT OF
MOMENTUM GOING TO SAY. WE HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO YEAH. THIS IS.
LEGISLATION WHAT DO YOU THOMAS
ON WE GET OUR BENCHMARK MUST
HIRE AND HE'LL BE YOUR LEADER.
THE PHARMACIST POLICY. SO YOU
PLEASE NOTE THERE'S A LESION
ACOSTA READY TOMORROW ENERGY
SWEET AND. WON A WHOLE. HOUSE
SYSTEM WITH. WE'LL BE HERE. AYE
AYE SIR. NO NO NO I THINK IT'S
GREAT I PROMISE NOT A THREAT. I
TRULY APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
AND I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE
OUGHT TO I THINK IT TO BE
HONEST A LOT OF MEMBERS DON'T.
KNOW ABOUT THIS FOR THE IT YEAH
IT'S A LITTLE OFF THE RADAR
SCREEN AND- YOU KNOW. WE HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE RUNNING AROUND
HERE WHO. YOU KNOW. CLAIM THAT
ANY CHANGE TO. LICENSURE
REQUIREMENT WILL CERTAINLY PUT
THE PUBLIC AT JEOPARDY OF ALL
SORTS OF TERRIBLE INFLICT
AFFECTIONS. AND YOU KNOW THERE
BUT THERE'S A THERE'S A SUCH A
IS THERE SUCH A COMPELLING CASE
IT'S BEEN MADE HERE TODAY AND I
THINK IT'S BEEN MADE. IN THE
PAST IS WHAT I JUST INVITE YOU
TO. CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
LEGISLATORS AND JUST HELP TO.
JUST BUILD AWARENESS I THINK OF
THIS THIS THIS ISSUE SOME NOT
SO I'D I'D APPRECIATE THIS IS A
GREAT DEAL. I WANTED OBVIOUSLY-THINK A LEAN AND SERRA AND
KELLY MAY FOR TAKING ALL MY
HARD QUESTIONS AND. YEAH YEAH
OKAY OKAY TO COME ON UP AND I
YEAH. OKAY OKAY HUSTLE SO CITY
MANAGER WILL CITY OF ONE ARRAY.
WE HAVE THREE MAJOR INSULATION
THE CITY FLUORIDE THAN A GROUP
WAS GOING TO SCHOOL COUNSELING
WHICH INSTITUTE AND TING
AMERICAL. WILL BE MISSING IN
THE TOWN ARE. NURSES DENTAL
HYGIENISTS. AND BEHAVIORAL
MENTAL HEALTH EXPERT THAT HELPS
WITH HOMELESSNESS. WE HAVE A
CASES ON THE PRESIDIO OF
MONTEREY WITH. STEP UP TO THE
PLATE. POINT TO WE HAVE THE
PERMIT STREAMLINING ACT IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT COULD
QUICKLY CHOIRS THOSE THIRTY
DAYS TO RE BY A TREE LOOK AND
REVIEW COMPLEX BUILDING PERMITS
THAT INCLUDES A QUAN EVERYTHING
ELSE. IT'S ASTONISHING TO ME
THAT IT TAKES FIFTY WORKING
DAYS TO LOOK AT TEACHER
ACCREDITATION THAT'S ON A GOOD
BENCHMARK EITHER SO I'D NEVER
USE THE WORD NO BRAINER BECAUSE
AS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT GUY THERE
IS NOTHING LIKE A LOCAL NO
BRAINER. AND YOU HAVE TO
CONSIDER ALL THIS BOB THIS IS
PRETTY CLOSE TO A SLAM DUNK TO
GET. TO GET TO A POSITIVE
IMPACT HERE AND DO A DIFFERENCE
FOR US IN THE IN OR LOOK ON
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE- THANK YOU SIR. SO THANK
YOU OKAY. OKAY COME COME ON UP
WHAT I'M I'M LITERALLY RUNNING
OFF TO SOMETHING SO I'M GONNA
PASS THE MICROPHONE THAT THE- I
I'M SO SORRY I THIS IS. A LONG
SCHEDULED THE- BAIT BUT AT SOME
OF THE PASSED THE GAVEL TO
CENTER ROSSER TO HEAR YOUR-
TESTIMONY ON WITH THE STAFF AND
CLOSE HEARING BUT- YOU MAY
PROCEED. YEAH PLEASE TAKE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR TIME WHICH
YOU. TAKE ALL THE TIME YOU
NEED. I JUST OUR OUR PEOPLE
BELIEVE ME THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
LISTEN TO THESE PROCEEDINGS
OUTSIDE OF THIS ROOM
OCCASIONALLY. AND IT'S AND SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO GET THE
MESSAGE ACROSS TO NOT ONLY
THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE HERE
TODAY. BUT THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT IN THIS ROOM WHO MAY BE
LISTENING SO PLEASE TAKE YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR BY
CALLING HIS A MEETING WITH OUR
LEADERS SO HE HAS TO GO. THANK
YOU I TWENTY SIX I'M I'M MY
NAME IS CARLY CLARK MY HUSBAND
IS THE WING COMMANDER OF A
DEALER FOR SPACE RURAL BEALE
AIR FORCE BASE. I'VE EITHER
BEEN IN THE AIRFORCE OR MERRY
TO IT FOR TWENTY YEARS I'M VERY
THANKFUL FOR THIS CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU FOR THAT I JUST TOOK
A COUPLE NOTES AND I WANTED TO.
ADDRESS MR GLAZER WAS ASKING
FOR SOME CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
DATA AND ALTHOUGH I CAN'T
PROVIDE YOU THAT I CAN PROVIDE
YOU SOME BEALE SPECIFIC DATA.
AND WON. THING OF NOTE THAT
CAME UP FROM A SURVEY THAT WE
SENT OUT TO OUR SEVEN THOUSAND.
US SERVICE MEMBERS ON THE BASE
WAS. ABOUT 21% OF OUR SPOUSES
HOLDING A LICENSE OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND OF
THOSE TWENTY PERCENT. 40% SAID
THAT THEY WERE UNWILLING TO
EVEN ATTEMPT TO PURSUE
TRANSFERRING THEIR LICENSE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO. WHILE
YOU TALK ABOUT THE BOARDS.
HAVING SOME ACCOUNTABILITY IN
TALKING ABOUT WHEN THEY'RE
GRANTED OR NOT GRANTED. THEY'RE
NOT GONNA CAPTURE THAT 40% OF
SAUCES THAT DON'T EVEN TRY IN
THE FIRST PLACE. SO I JUST
WANTED TO. TO MAKE NOTE OF THAT
THE OTHER THING THAT I WAS.
WANTED TO BRING. UP WAS. OUR
ORDERS PROCESS THE MILITARY
ORDERS AND HOW THAT WORKS AND-
A LOT OF TIMES IF WE GET
NOTIFICATION. MONTHS AND MONTHS
IN ADVANCE. THAT WE ARE
TRANSFERRING SOMEWHERE. BUT WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THOSE.
PAPER ORDERS YET. AND IF THERE
WERE SOME WAVES FOR OUR SPOUSES
TO BE ABLE TO START SOME OF
THESE PROCESSES WITH THE BOARD.
FOR ACTUALLY. AGAIN CALIFORNIA.
SO HELPFUL. A LOT OF THE BOARDS
REQUIRE THAT OUR SPOUSES BE.
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA ALREADY
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN START THE
PROCESS. AND SO THAT OBVIOUSLY
PUTS US MONTHS BEHIND AND THEN
THE LAST ONE I WANTED TO MAKE
WAS OUR CHILD CARE AND THAT
CAME UP QUITE A BIT. THE BASE.
AT THE OTHER FOR SPACE AND I
KNOW ALL THE OTHER
INSTALLATIONS WE DO PROVIDE
CHILDCARE ON THE BASE. AND WE
ALSO PROVIDE. FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. THE ISSUE AS- WE CAN
GET THEM. SYNCED ON OUR BASE
FAIRLY. IT'S GETTING THEM
LICENSED OUT THE GATE IN THE
STATE. THE CHALLENGE. TO BE
ABLE TO SET UP A DAYCARE. IN
HOME CARE. THE HELP IS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO THAT. HURTS OUR
CHILD CARE. NEEDS FOR THE BASE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME APPRECIATE THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS ANYONE ELSE ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
I'M FIRST LIEUTENANT PRETTY
CURRY AND THE CHIEF OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ABOUT BILLION FOR SPACE
I WORK FOR MRS CLARKSON'S
HUSBAND. THE ONE THING THAT
WOULD BE AS A COMMUNICATOR
THERE'S A LOT OF THE POINTS
THAT ARE IN THE BUSINESS CODE
OR THAT ARE STATED ARE VERY
VAGUE. SO THERE WAS WAYS TO
BETTER DEFINE THEM AS POLICY IS
BEING LOOKED AT. AS A SOMEONE
WHO CONTROLS THE COMMUNICATION
ASSETS AT MY BASE I CAN TAKE
THOSE AND PROVIDE THOSE LOCALLY
AND SO CAN MY PEERS ACROSS THE
UNITED THEIR FORCE OR THE DOD
AS A WHOLE BUT- STATING
COMPARABLE WERE STATING THAT
ITS EXPEDITED. WHAT DOES THAT
EVEN MEAN AND HAVING
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE SYSTEM SO
THAT I CAN PROVIDE THAT LOCALLY
TO OUR SPOUSES WERE WORK WITH
THE PROGRAMS THAT EXIST
HONORING SOLUTIONS THAT.
PROVIDE THE NEWCOMERS PROCESS
THAT WE TAKE IN OUR NEW MEMBERS
THAT WE CAN PUSH THAT OUT BUT
THE DATA AND THE ACTUAL DETAILS
OF IT IS NOT. SO WHEN THOSE
QUESTIONS COME TO MY OFFICE
WHICH THEY- OFTEN WILL DO
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GOOGLE BEALE
AIR FORCE BASE MY OFFICE POPS
UP BECAUSE WE PROVIDE THAT
PUBLIC TOUCH POINT. THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE INFORMATION LIKE I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO FIND
THEM OR I DON'T KNOW. THE NOT
CONGLOMERATE. IN A IN A CENTRAL
POINT WHERE IT'S DIFFICULT
ALTHOUGH ALL GO INTO THE- FOR
LACK OF BETTER TERM A GOOGLE
HOLE TRYING TO FIND THIS
INFORMATION. AND IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE TO ME SO. IF THAT IS
THE FINE THEN I CAN TAKE THAT
AND I CAN DO SOMETHING AT MY
LOCAL LEVEL TO HELP WITH THAT
PROCESS. AND THEN EVEN JUST THE
TERM SHALL WHICH THERE IS A
LAWYER FROM OUR INSULATION. WHO
IS. MARRIED SHE IS A PRACTICING
LAWYER SHE'S MARRIED TO OUR OUR
ACTUAL HEAD LAWYER ON THE
INSULATION. SHE STATED THAT
SHALL IS JUST A FANCY WORD FOR
ME. A SO THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT PROCESS
IN OUR REGULATIONS. THERE'S
SHALL MUST AND WILL. MUST AND
WILL YOU WILL DO THAT IS IT YOU
ARE REQUIRED BY THAT REGULATION
TO DO THAT. SHELL IS A
CONSIDERATION OF SOMETHING THAT
ONCE YOU'VE COMPLETED THE
OTHERS. YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TAKE SOME RISK IN NOT DOING
THAT. STILL HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE TO SHALL IS VERY
DIFFICULT. BECAUSE IT JUST SAYS
YOU CAN'T DO IT IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY SAY THAT YOU WILL.
SO JUST FROM THE COMMUNICATION
SEPARATE IF. IF THAT'S
CONSIDERED THAN I CAN DO
SOMETHING AT MY LEVEL. BUT
WITHOUT THAT. MY HANDS ARE KIND
OF TIED TRYING TO HELP SPOUSES
FIND THIS INFORMATION AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WELL I WANT TO
THANK A YES PLEASE. MARK PALMER
FROM THE SAN DIEGO MILITARY
ADVISORY COUNCIL ALSO
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE GONNA
COMMUNITIES ALLIANCE I JUST
LIKE TO COMMENT THERE WAS A
QUESTION EARLIER ON WHERE IS
THE DATA. FOR CALIFORNIA THERE
IS DATA TO ITS NATIONAL DATA
THAT WAS POINTED OUT HERE IT'S
FAIRLY RECENT AND IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT SPOUSES IN OUR STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SPOUSES HAVE
A VERY HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT 16%
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HOW
CALIFORNIA FLIGHTS THAT WE HAVE
VERY LOW UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHT NOW
WE NEED WE ARE SEARCHING. FOR
SKILLED WORKERS IN SAN DIEGO IN
PARTICULAR SPOUSES HAVE THOSE
SKILLS THE IMPEDIMENT IS SIR
LICENSURE LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION SO HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT. THIS UP FOR
SOMEONE TO THANK EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR ATTENDING
AND IN PARTICULAR THOSE WHO.
TOOK THE TIME TO PREPARE AND TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF I'M THANKING
YOU ON BEHALF OF MY TWO CHAIRS
WHO WERE HERE. A BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS IN THIS PARTICULAR
SELECT COMMITTEE. OF THIS IS A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
ALL OF US IN THE LEGISLATURE
SUMMER MORE INFORMED ON IT THAN
OTHERS BUT ALL ARE INTERESTED
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE IDENTIFY
THE PROBLEMS AND WE SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS. HAVING A CHAIR BEEN A
BUDGET PERSON APPEAR FOR THE.
INCLUDING MY SEVENTH YEAR
APPEAR ON IN ONE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THE OTHER IN FOR
SIX YEARS I DID THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR STATE TO
GOVERNMENT STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO. MANY OF THESE
LICENSING AGENCIES IN ONE FORM
OR ANOTHER WERE IN FRONT OF ME
AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER AND
THEIR LOT UP THERE A LOT OF
THEM. WE DID NOT GET TO THIS
POINT IN CALIFORNIA OVERNIGHT
EACH OF THESE OCCUPATIONS IN
THE AGENCIES THAT REGULATE
LICENSE THEM. OF DEVELOP THE
RULES FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
LISTENING TO A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS. SO TRYING TO DEAL
WITH THIS AS A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL ISSUE. IS GOING TO BE VERY
DIFFICULT IT'S NOT THE
DIFFICULTY DOESN'T MEAN WE
DON'T TRY TO DO IT AND TRY TO
SUCCEED AND HOPEFULLY SUCCEED
BUT IT WILL TAKE A LITTLE BIT
OF EFFORT. TO TRY TO PUT THIS
TOGETHER THE ONE THING THAT
OCCURRED TO ME AS I WAS
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY
TODAY AND AGAIN I DON'T SPEAK
FOR MY CHAIRS IS JUST RICHARD
ROTH. A KING. IS THE WHATEVER
WE DO IN REGARDLESS OF THE PART
NOR EIGHT SEE THEIR DEALING
WITH INCLUDED CONTROLS
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION.
JOB NUMBER ONE NEEDS TO BE ON
IT AT LEAST ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS. GETTING THEM THE
MILITARY SPOUSE PROPERLY
LICENSED OR CERTIFICATED IN
ANOTHER STATE INTO A JOB AS
FAST AS POSSIBLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT. FITS THE
SKILLS AND THE EXPERIENCE LEVEL
OF THE PERSON INVOLVED. AND WE
NEED TO DO THAT AND THEN WE
NEED TO ALLOW THE REST OF THE
PROCESS TO CATCH UP AS OPPOSED
TO DOING IT THE OTHER WAY NOW
THERE MAY BE PARTICULAR.
OCCUPATIONS PARTICULAR JOBS
WHERE FOR SOME VERY IMPORTANT
REASONS WE CAN'T DO THAT. BUT
THOSE SHOULD BE THE EXCEPTION
RATHER THAN THE RULE. SO I AM
PERSONALLY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS I KNOW
I'M COMMITTED AYE AYE BY THIS
OF INDICATED WITH MY- FULL
LAWYER IN THE ROOM. WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO LAWYERS
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK EVERY
OTHER OCCUPATION. FOR A LIFE OF
ME I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
HEALTH CARE FEELS WHY THERE'S A
STEP MUCH DIFFICULTY GETTING
SOMEONE WHO'S APPROPRIATELY
LICENSED AS A PHYSICIAN OR A
NURSE OR OF. CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER WORKER SOMEONE ELSE IN
ANOTHER STATE INTO A JOB IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WHY IT
TAKES SO LONG AND WHY IT'S SO
FRUSTRATING. AS A ELECTED
DEALING WITH CONSTITUENTS IN
THE SENATE DISTRICT. A WE HAVE
IN OUR DISTRICT WE HAVE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE NOT TO BE
CRITICAL AND THIS WAS A COUPLE
YEARS AGO. WITH THE NURSING
BOARD AND TRYING TO GET NURSING
NURSES APPROPRIATELY
CREDENTIALED IN A TIMELY
FASHION IN CALIFORNIA SO HAVING
SAID ALL THAT. I'M COMMITTED
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORK WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND TO MAKE
SURE THE MILITARY SPOUSES.
SECURE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT IN
THEIR FIELD OF SPECIALTY IN
CALIFORNIA AS FAST AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT WE CAN HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
BE SUCCESSFUL AND FRANKLY.
PRESERVE THE MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS THEY WERE YOUR
PRIVILEGE TO CONTINUE TO HAVE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO
IF THERE'S NOTHING ELSE. STAFF
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU FOR TO